[Music]
[Music]
it is
so tight in the air things monsters
before we kick off the last day of
preliminaries
eight players will qualify for the
quarterfinals four players will be
knocked out and believe it or not
no one is safe so we are in for a very
exciting day of chess
welcome to the champions chess tour
welcome to my humble abode
this time i'll be playing from moscow
but here is where i live
[Music]
oh look at the bark this is my usual
work spot
and i just want to see
there's the old mouse i use for all the
other tournaments it can be a little bit
dark in here this is a crucial moment
now i think levon he's bobbing faster
than evan
i'll certainly try to be in killer mode
from the get-go
for winning the skilling open is not
enough i need some more
the air things monsters is the first
major in the champions chess tour and
today it is
all about qualifying for those
quarter-finals and to help us everything
that will be happening we have
women's grand master ivanka housecat and
grandmaster david howell and david
yesterday 21 out of 24 games
ended in draws what was that all about
yeah maybe something was
in the air something in the water it's
not what we like to see all those
drawers
but i think today it's set the stage for
a very exciting
uh a few rounds of chess i'm hoping for
a lot more fight though in the players
yeah because it almost seemed like the
mentality for the players was to play it
safe was to play for those draws
what will be the mentality today well i
think we're going to see a big
combination of the two there are some
players who
certainly will play completely safe and
not
take any risk at all and then there are
those players in the danger zone
who cannot do this at all and they will
have to come at their opponents like
vikings
berserking their way to victory because
it is all about now qualifying for the
quarterfinals what will the next days in
the air things masters look like
oh well this is what everything is good
building up to there's going to be the
knockout stages and the quarterfinalists
will play
two head-to-head matches comprising of
four rapid games
per day and if the results are tied
things heat up with a blitz and maybe
even an
armageddon games and this continues
under the semi-finals
and until the fight until the finals and
then oh my god if we're gonna find out
who the winner of the air things masters
is they'll walk away with 60
000 and a golden ticket to the grand
final in september
and david with only yeah 12 players 11
rounds of preliminaries
how are the players feeling before
kicking off the last day of
preliminaries
i think they'll be more nervous than
ever the first couple of days
it showed that nobody's really feeling
confident nobody's really
stamped their mark on this tournament
and um as we mentioned nobody's safe
there's only one and a half points
difference between first place and last
place
anything can happen anything can happen
now yesterday only three games ended
with a winner and a loser
but even with all the draws we had some
really exciting chess
the second day of the air things masters
saw the early leaders happy to keep the
status quo
are we about to see a result i think we
might be about to see it
oh no that was over before i even got
time to explain the opening wesley so
smiling there
just laughing out there it's
disappointing when this happens because
you kind of
you know in chess is a spectator sport
you kind of want some
blood and thrill that draw was just the
beginning
for the morning weary americans wesley
so he's only been by
playing chest today for 15 minutes
after three rounds he's just gotta man
up and start trying to fight because he
won the first series
he knows he can win most of the game so
rather than shaking hands too quickly
you know fights
it must be said even some of the short
draws
were spectacular they repeat the
position like this three times this is
called the wimp mill
technique the funny thing about that is
though normally when you see a stunning
tactic like that
it ends up with someone winning but in
this case wesley uses a stunning tactic
to get himself that important draw so
well done wesley
both nakamura and so ended the day with
four draws
but they are still on route to
qualifying for the quarterfinals
much to nakamura's
he joy nakamura he just he started
laughing for like
20 seconds after that game against
wesley so he actually laughed longer
than that game lasted yeah but was that
so funny to him
and how clearly it was i mean i'm glad
he found it funny um
yeah but uh definitely he's setting the
scene for today
because everything is so tense and uh
yeah we're super excited here in the
studio to find out who's gonna get
eliminated
and we have to say tell us at home who
everyone is cheering for who do you
think is going to get eliminated
we're dying to know and you can do this
by tweeting us
on the hashtag chess champs and we'll
feature them on the show
definitely the players need all the help
they can get today because it is
so tight on the standings list let's
take a look at what it looks like before
we head into round
nine of eleven so we do have those six
players on four
and a half point david and then
alexander gretcher kenyan pogba actually
fighting just behind there
on four points and then those four
players on uh
on the bottom here they're not qualified
right now
that's right those guys are in the
danger zone a loss or two for
anishkiri or david anton at the bottom
there will eliminate them
meanwhile the ones i think who will be
the most nervous are alexander grishoek
in place seven and jana pomonacci in
place eight
those guys are so close to dropping out
just one bad game
and their chances will be gone and will
players you've encountered four and a
half points
feel safe here or do you think they also
need to play for wins today
yeah definitely it's a risky strategy to
play it safe because
like you say you know it could be one a
bad game and that's it they're out
so i think everyone will be going in
with a very gung-ho mentality
and getting ready for those victories
and if we have this situation david with
several
players on the same score what decides
who qualifies for quarter finals
so if there is a big bunch of players on
the same score there are three
potential tiebreakers ways that we will
separate them
the first will be the head-to-head
results then we will look at the number
of wins that they've scored
throughout the tournament if the players
still can't be separated in this
unlikely scenario then we will be
getting the calculator out we will be
trying to work out a complicated math
equation this is what i made at home
earlier
um yes it will get very very nervy the
glitter calculator you said yesterday
that your skills in mathematics is not
too great but this is your this is what
you have to do today david exactly this
uh
i know what one plus one is everything
else i need to work out on the
calculator
all right it's going to be complicated
no doubt about it when it's
so tight just one half point between top
and bottom you're like
yeah absolutely so much will they won't
they i don't know anything can happen
and i'm so looking forward to it and uh
well um
magnus carlsen we haven't talked too
much about him he is one of those six
players on four and a half points
um he did actually he was one of the few
players yesterday who did get a win
in the first round against danielle dubo
but the world champion he is not too
happy with his play so far
it's about trying to be uh solid
tomorrow not
not flaps i have two tough games as
black so
i assume they're gonna come at me pretty
if they are but
as long as i can sort of stay solid i
should be fine maybe i can get a
win tomorrow as well so that i can get a
good seat but overall the tournament is
okay
uh the play are great i need to win two
games i think i've got two whites so
that's going to be
the plan you know it's very unfortunate
to be in the situation because of course
for everybody now who is on a good score
they're just there
chilling and playing safe against each
other
just waiting for the tournament for the
qualification phase to be over
and people like me who are you know in
the gutter we have to
fight uh our way back so it's going to
be hard but
i feel my place been okay my shape is
okay so if i get a bit luckier maybe
i'll manage to to win and not lose
yeah with two wins i'll i'll make it but
it's going to be very hard i'll try my
best
anish geary one of definitely the big
profiles in chess david he was
excellent in the skilling open in in the
first few days
do you think he will qualify or or is he
just not looking too good in this
tournament
i think he still has decent chances he
is in last place at the moment joined
last place but
we interviewed him yesterday he said he
was feeling good he felt he was actually
playing quite well
despite the results um he's such an
interesting interesting personality
and such a fascinating player to watch
i've got my fingers crossed for him
he is facing maximum vaccination in the
first game today both players need to
fight to actually
qualify who do you believe in is the
best in that matchup
wow it's gonna be such a great game you
have a anish geary who is very well
prepared and then you have
maxine bachelorette who's in fact mr
tricky he's got such a tactical style
and in fact mvl has been tweeting so he
knows he has an uphill task and he says
he's
trying to achieve the home run tomorrow
with a blue sign
of validation and there he has a picture
of himself with an
air things device so he's been given the
all go ahead from air things because
he's had great air quality
there you can see the tweet
he's been mr perfect in that respect i
think he's been clear first there
but uh yeah he definitely has an uphill
task today
black pieces against anita geary gonna
be a tough one fantastic and we know
geary we've been following his co2
levels which have been
horrible so i mean maximum may be
leading
the way in air quality now the chassis
chester is all about online chess the
players are sitting at home
playing and that means the time
difference is an aspect here some
players are playing in the morning some
are playing
at night in the evening we see hikar
nakamura it's just so interesting every
day
when we take this map up it's not even 6
00 am for him
david have we seen hikara been tired so
far
maybe that's why he was laughing in the
video earlier nakamura maybe he's just
so sleep deprived
that being said i think as the days go
on he will start to
um warm up and get used to that i mean
he'll recover from that
type of jet lag in a way um and yeah i
think the best is yet to come from those
american players who are yet to
really shine um in those morning times
and we see anishigiri and maxim vashiela
grav the two players who will
we will follow in the first round ivanka
playing in the same time zone
three o'clock uh almost there now is
this a perfect time for chess players to
play
i think so i mean this is the standard
time where chess players play
so they're very very used to all this
and they would have had a chance
to actually relax let's have a good
night's sleep
prepare a little bit so they will be in
optimum shape and we still don't know
where magnus carlsen is the clock we in
the coordinator there was magnus carlson
any clue so far david
um we know it's somewhere warm he's been
looking very flushed uh
during the games and we saw the air
quality it's very humid where he is
that being said we have no idea big
mystery all right well
we are heading in to the first round of
day
three in the air things masters it is
now all about qualifying for
those quarterfinals so let's take a look
at the games
in round nine we will have alexander
grishock facing magnus carlsen ivanka
who is the favorite
well definitely this is going to be so
exciting grishok of course such an
aggressive player but i do have to say
magnus carlsen he is the big boss he is
the champ
i think magnus carlsen is a favorite and
then we have the american hikaru
nakamura he's going to play david anton
he is in bottom of the table
uh david is nakamura the huge favorite
in this game
i think he has to be despite the fact
he's starting at 6 a.m in the morning
he did beat david anton in the skilling
open in the first leg of the champions
chess tour
it's hard to look past nakamura and then
an all-russian encounter with jan
naponati facing
daniel dubo two players we actually had
them talk together
the other night ivanka who's the
favorite amongst these two
well duboff has been so impressive for
me he has already played
the game of the tournament such a
fantastic victory against
david anton so i'm hoping for devops and
then we have
levon aronian who's looked so solid he
is facing panther hari krishna
who has not been too solid david do you
think levon aronian here will get off to
a great start
well hare krishna he needs to take those
risks he's in those bottom four places
right now so
levon he'll be trying to keep things
solid and wait for his chance to counter
attack if
if harry krishna pushes too hard and
then wesley saw the winner of the
skilling open he's playing team
rajabo and wesley so he played so many
super fast draws yesterday does that
mean he saved his energy for this game
well in theory yes but you know i'm sure
karma will have something to say
you know those quick draws might come to
buy might come back to bite him today
and then we have the game that we will
follow the one we mentioned it is
between anish geary and maxime
variolograph two of the biggest profiles
in chess
but they are right now outside the
qualification for quarter finals
this will be very tense david yes this
is the big one of the round
both players need to win and that makes
for a very
fighting game we also see there on the
screen that they're head-to-head
scores in online well in speed chess in
rapid and blitz chess
and it's clear who has well who's in
this
ascendancy maxine vashila grav with 12
wins
anishigiri only with five wins that
means maybe maxine vacherov has the
psychological edge heading into this
game
what do you think is anish giri's
mentality heading into this
ivanka and here we see it we are just
about to to start it's one minute
until we start off round nine the first
round of day three in the preliminaries
most of the players
are ready sitting by the words we are
missing a few of them they need to get
to the boards
because the very exciting the last day
of preliminaries is about to start you
might go what's your expectations now
well i'm expecting a niche to play his
normal game he
is normally a very sharp player he's
very well prepared i'm expecting him
just to continue just to put the last
two days behind him
and just play some good chess and there
we have maxim coming to
the computer what can we judge by the
looks of these players now david
well maxime looks relaxed as ever we've
seen him with only 20 seconds left on
his clock
eating an apple in the past he's very
very calm very cool
anish will be doing those last minute
preparations and key
i think in this game is that anish has
the white pieces he said in the
interview yesterday he thought that
might be
the decisive factor he feels much more
confident when he's white
we are waiting for anish giri to
join the computer he is doing his final
preparations a very important day for
nishkiri
with the white pieces and in these three
last rounds for niche gear he does
actually have two
white games and oh david we have started
that's right and anish giri
but he's making the moves yes and i
think we're heading towards your
favorite opening kaya ah
naidorf that's right we have seen the
sicilian defense anishikari opening with
the king's pawn on the first turn that's
not something that we always see from
initially
he tends to um play other openings so
this shows he's in the mood to fight
he's
wow and maxine vasily grove actually
goes away from the sicilian night off
maxine he's been playing the sicilian
night of the whole of his career
so he's trying something a bit different
this time um both players
trying to surprise each other at this
early stage yeah
is there because the moves are coming
out but he's just not visible
but you know anish is not just a great
competitor he's also a great tweeter and
he came up with a great tweet
did you know that being high on co2 can
cause a lack of creativity when
composing a tweet
other negative effects of high co2
levels concentration today at 3 pm cet
it seems to me there is also another
side effect that
can cause invisibility there we have it
the air quality
needs to measure that um and he has
he has made a move david that's right so
anish giri he's brought all of his
pieces out at the moment he's
brought his knights out the white
knights into the center of the board the
white bishops are nicely in the center
too
and if we bring up the analysis board we
can see why anish geary played that last
move
white's last move was to bring his queen
forward one square
nicely centralized doing a good job but
most importantly his king
white king now has two fantastic options
he can choose to bring it to the left
side or the right side depending on
which side he thinks will be safer
if anishigiri brings his king to the
left side here and castles
um i think maximum vascular also brought
his queen out if anish giri brings his
king to this left side of the board
then we will see a very very attacking
game and he's giving he'll throw
everything forward
on this side he'll push all of his pawns
on the right side and he's going to
go he's going to throw everything in it
looks like he's gambling on this game
very critical moment here which side
will anish geary put his king on the
right or the left
and we do actually know because these
two players are um
not on the same score geary is half a
point behind maximum vagiela grab but
but we do know if players are on the
same score eventually then it is all
about those head-to-heads number of wins
all of that
so it is very important actually to get
the wins against the players that you
might
end up on the same score as that's right
i mean not only are these two direct
rivals
in the standings table but also anish
giri
remember he has lost a couple of games
so if he does manage to put those wins
together
he'll be ahead on those those number of
wins his tie breaks will be better than
most of the others so anishigiri he does
have something to play for
um let's see whether that rebounds on
him if he pushes too hard
he's playing very aggressive so far in
this game as white i love that about
chess that we can actually see
from the like the first few moves if
they are playing aggressively or if they
are just
and that means i love it when this
happens this means war
i remember when i was a child and i
discovered this strategy that when your
opponent went one way with their king
you can go the other way
and attack like crazy oh made chess easy
exactly and um anishigiri he did show
his aggressive his ambitious intentions
in this game
by putting his king on that side
meanwhile maxine vasily grav tries to
counter
by putting his knight on the edge of the
board we always say this is inadvisable
this is a bit of a risky strategy
but black with that last move with his
knight on the edge of the board is
attacking a white bishop right now
so um maxine vachelagrav he's not lying
down he's not just
developing his last move bringing this
knight here does attack this bishop this
bishop is now attacked twice by black's
queen
and black's knight it's only defended
once by the white queen therefore this
bishop has to move
i expect to see any giri not spend too
long and drop his bishop back to a safe
square
one of these two and ladies and
gentlemen
wesley so has played a draw
three minutes three minutes wow
is that his longest game so far this
year
longest game in the tournament i just
can't believe it it's
almost like he's mocking us now just ah
look at me i'll do one more
fast roll nice it's uh
yeah speechless yeah i mean i i would
really like there to be a system to
actually
discourage this type of quick yes and uh
one of the things that i came up with
is that instead of having like tie
breaks these standard chai bakes i think
that they should be
random tie breaks maybe they have all
the players lined up who have qualified
for thai break
and then you have the computer select
them random like
[Music]
that's fine oh you know just have some
fun element
especially when it's all play all
because it doesn't matter exactly
yeah it's just a shame i think i mean
i'm a massive fan of wesley sews
we saw in the skilling open he beat
magnus carson in that final when he
wants to play well he can
it's just such a shame to see him kind
of just kind of cruise through these
first rounds not really playing proper
chess
but luckily we do have some action in
the game that we are following i'm just
looking at the bar and it has
gone quite significantly over chinese
near the side yeah that's right i'm
very surprised by maxine bashiligrav's
last move um if we bring up the board
we can see that he did push a pawn in
the center as black in this position
black pushed his central pawn forward
one square he is attacking the white
knight forcing that knight to move
but if you look at it black pawn has
already moved once
and pawns can move twice on the first go
he's actually wasted a move in a way he
could have pushed this pawn two squares
forward a bit earlier on instead he
moved
it forward once and then moved it
forward again losing time and meanwhile
anishkiri saved his night in the middle
there
offering a trade of these knights um
these knights might leave the board but
one thing i think
will be an important factor sooner
rather than later is the fact that black
king
is in the middle it still hasn't decided
where it's going black is behind in
peace development look at white's pieces
all of them are out all of them are
doing something black's army is still at
home asleep
yeah absolutely we're actually in new
territory now with that night retreat so
this has never been seen
before and everyone on twitter is
looking forward to this game so much we
have a tweet from gyorgy
comes i'm sorry i can't pronounce the
surname
anish geary versus nvl is going to be a
very interesting game
both players are going to be fighting
for staying in this tournament
thank you very much georgie for that
tweet and we also have another tweet
from chess meme x who says everyone is
playing for a draw while anish is
playing for results
this is 2020
right oh that's a fantastic tweet yeah
anish geary being so known for all the
draws
and here he is fighting that's right
2020's turned everything on his head
clearly yeah
i think anish okay yes he has this
reputation for draws but he's
maybe not like wesley so wesley so likes
to play for those quick draws
just kill the game immediately and
ishquiri he tries to fight it's just
sometimes he lacks that final killer
instinct that's why he fails to win some
games and
that's why um occasionally he does have
those string of draws
um meanwhile anishigiri playing it safe
just tucking the white king into the
corner
very very sensible move there by inikiri
so will
um maxim here with his king still uh in
the middle of the board here
um or in his center where will he castle
and will he castle
um he'll have to think about it and the
longer the black king stays in the
center
and the kind of the bigger the risks
will be a bit later on
when things start to open up that black
king needs to commit itself
it's just which side and i do think the
black king will head towards the right
side of the board
the opposite side to white and therefore
once that happens
we'll see a race white wall attack on
the right black will attack on the left
it's going to be who gets to the
opposition king first
so the most normal situation is that
both players cancel to the same side
that's right yeah what are typically
typically games like when they cancel to
different sides often quite crazy wild
when kings are on the same side of the
board it's just harder to attack the
opponent because you risk opening up
your own king at the same time
but now if your opponent's castled on
the other side you can just think
oh i have a free hand i have no no risk
i can just push
all the pawns forward and there we see
maxine bachelor he's moved his bishop
forward one square but he's cleared the
way
for the black king to head towards that
right side now wow so we will have it
different side castling and we do see
the the air quality for maximum vaginal
growth now we have partnered up with air
things
some of the players have uh put these uh
things in the in the rooms where they're
playing and we can actually monitor
their air quality and maxim is it's okay
but the co2 level is
not great it's going to be interesting
to see for niche geary if that's
ah there we have it oh wow that's that's
red that means
co2 level is still very bad for nichiri
yeah it definitely affected him i think
on the first couple of days it's no
coincidence that he
he seemed to struggle a bit for energy
maybe and those co2 levels
very very high that being said if he he
did say
if he does open the window he gets a bit
cold so he's just choosing the
the lesser evil yeah now it's definitely
such a fascinating thing for me to have
these devices that we can actually
look at and see the statistics because
i've never ever thought about air
quality being perhaps correlated into
uh quality of play and here we have it
actually it's no coincidence
and definitely now with the online
format whether players are just sitting
in different rooms they're not
sitting with the same air quality
they're sitting in different rooms in
their homes yeah
exactly and it's just brilliant i mean
and it's also not just for chess because
i can see how this can impact like if
you're working from home you know we
spend
yeah so much time sitting at the desk
and you know if
if the the carbon dioxide levels are
just too high then you're going to get
sluggish and it's going to have a really
negative impact on your health right so
i just love this
i agree um well the cool air quality for
maximum washer legra was a little bit
better than furniture
but i'm guessing by the bar and why you
guys have been saying that manish geary
is
better on the chessboard that's right um
personally i like anish guru's position
i also like anish giri's position um i
mean give me a position where i can
throw my
pawns forward and start going crazy with
them i just love it and
you can see that's that pawn has inched
its way
slowly up the board but it's getting
ready for another pawn to start
advancing forward
so i i can't wait to see those pawns go
on the right side
uh a bit of a waiting game by inikiri
there he's asking black to commit his
king
before white's pawns start rushing up
that right side
basically anish was saying okay i dare
you i dare you to castle your king to
that side
because you know i'm going to attack you
but maxine vasily graves black says no
i'm still going to wait
both sides waiting black just developing
his bishop to the middle there
another sensible move for viewers though
who are new to us we should explain the
bar we've mentioned it a few times
it's that purple bar just above the
player's cameras um if it slides towards
the left it means that
white is doing very well it slides
towards the right then black is in
charge
at the moment it says 0.9 that means
that white has an advantage
it's almost a pawns worth of an
advantage but
that could all change in one move
exactly right because
because the thing is the great thing
about chess is that anish
actually isn't a pawn up the material is
level so that just means the momentum is
on his side
and that if he doesn't continue in the
correct way well that
advantage can start to slowly evaporate
and that's it you know the initiative
could immediately oh look at the bar
with that move
it just com was that a bad move by an
ishgiri
um i don't think it was necessarily a
bad move maybe there were better moves
in the position i think that black maybe
has now an opportunity um
to attack on the other side of the board
if we do bring up the analysis board we
can see what i think
maxine vazquez should do we saw anish
giri with his last move push this pawn
he wants to throw everything forward on
this right side
in anticipation that the king the black
king will also be on the side of the
board
but the key thing is that maxine vashti
graph he hasn't committed yet his king
still has flexibility
it can go either side later on meanwhile
he should
leave his king there he should leave the
black king and start attacking on this
side
both sides should push their pawns
forward if maxine vazquez pushes this
pawn
he will attack the white knight black's
attack is maybe slightly quicker than
the whites
than white's attack right now purely
because white has already committed his
king
all right and it is maximum vajrayana
thinking now
and well it is a huge and a
tough competition on the chessboard for
the players but we want to
involve you guys in a twitter quiz
as well um we can do this move first
before we start the quiz david
yeah lots and lots of moves there
black's just attacked this white knight
the white knight ran away
but it is on the edge of the board we've
said this so many times knights on the
side of the board are not happy
nights on the rim are dim and uh
meanwhile
white had to put his knight on the edge
of the board maxine vashly grav as black
said no
my knight was terrible on the edge he's
brought it towards the center and
actually the last couple of moves have
gone in maxine bachelor's favor
um black centralizing his knight while
forcing his opponent to misplace his own
wow all right well i don't know if max
and marcia allegra has a pet
at home uh that is cheering for him but
we do know that a lot of the players do
have
pets at home we've seen um levon aronian
with his dog
panchik yes panchook and we've seen
wesley so he's got his two cats
yeah look at that lavon brought his dog
on
and he said his dog is always there
loving it when he plays good moves and
then we have
i think it's sanzibar that is his name
the sansiva
yeah and i know pognatio also has a cat
and
i think it's called richie or ricky or
something so
so a lot of chess pets and that's why uh
the quiz for today you aren't guys all
about pets
exactly we decided to get a bit creative
with our quiz and ask you
what is the best chess inspired name
for a pet and you can tweet us your
answers
using the hashtag chess champs and even
better if you have pictures
then please use instagram with the same
hashtag
and show us those pets and remember it's
gonna be so much fun
but yeah remember what is the best chess
inspired name for a pet
so get thinking send us your pictures on
instagram send us your tweets
we would love to feature them on the
show i had a i had a suggestion
yeah you should uh you should do it i
thought it was quite good yeah
cat sparrow cat sparrow
or it could be just bobby fish if you
have a fish
bobby goldfish you definitely put some
food
i'm going to be thinking about this all
day now all right well
it is a niche gear the invisible lani
shire thinking about
his next move now um
he is quite a lot down on the clock now
david should
this be worrying for niche actually just
before the game i was wondering what
might
be the decisive factor and the clock
times
kind of hinting that anishigiri is not
as confident as he usually is he has
been affected by those first two days
he's
maybe slowed down a bit he's being a bit
indecisive we're still at an early stage
and maxine vazquez on the other side
on the other hand is famous for playing
extremely quickly
he's never seems to be behind on the
clock he's always
very practical he's happy to play those
moves which are good enough he's not
always looking for the perfect move
maybe anishikari is just trying to be a
bit too perfectionist right now
well it's fun to watch the bar now it's
swinging back and forth it seems both
players are not playing the perfect
moves here
that's right and we should we should
mention again the bar it is
the ideal move it's what the computer
the kind of all-seeing
uh omnipotent computer um judges to be
the evaluation of the position but these
guys are humans
they're geniuses but they're humans as
well and um they're just playing the
moves that they think make the most
sense
um and they don't have the time on the
clock to always look for the best move
every time
that's what's so exciting it makes chess
a real sport yeah is it sometimes like
that when you're playing because now for
the last few moves we've seen that the
bar
when when the players made a move the
bar has gone the opposite way
is it sometimes like that that you just
don't want to make a move because you
feel like any move you make is just
gonna worsen the situation for yourself
yeah it can be
that can happen um certainly when you
feel that you're losing the thread when
you feel like okay i have an advantage
and you haven't played the best moves
and suddenly that advantage kind of
seems to be disappearing
and you just know that okay you really
want to do something but you don't
really know what to be doing
i mean it happened to one of my friends
he was playing victiana and one of the
former world champions and he was three
pawns up
and then he kept then three pawns became
two pawns and he was like i really want
to offer a draw but drawers were not
allowed
and then two pawns became one pawn and
that's it he lost so
yeah sometimes better just not to make a
move and anish geary he moved his knight
that's right and anish giri with white
there just retreating a night
but he's trying to get rid of black's
best piece this is just in general quite
a good piece of advice for everyone
for beginners for grandmasters if you
don't have a plan
if you're not sure what to aim for just
think about which piece of yours can be
improved or
which piece of your opponents you want
to get rid of and if we bring up the
analysis board we can see
this is a very sensible reply from anish
giri and i think that probably the best
move in the position he brought his
knight back
he's eyeing up black's strongest piece
this is the only black piece
in the enemy half so in white's
territory and he's just trying to get
rid of that now with his knight his
bishop and his queen
three pieces attacking this black knight
maxi vacherov has to do something about
this
right now you have to that that night
that black knight is in the enemy camp
he needs to be getting rid of it's good
philosophy just to get rid of those
enemy pieces
and yeah i really like this move by
anish giri
and uh yeah we have a great tweet from
jurgen lutsy says anish giri seems to
have activated his
cloaking device it does look like that
he will mobilize all his available
resources
to make it to the quarterfinals and go
anish go
it's like that invisibility cloak in
harry potter exactly
when you want to do the most damage you
just hide yourself i must admit it's a
bit disconcerting just to see a blank
screen and the moves just keep appearing
it would be cooler though if we could
see the hand move
an invisible hand that would be even
more creepy
yeah i had that invisibility cloak on my
wish list for my birthday for many years
i was so disappointed that it didn't
exist for normal people okay so we know
um yeah i expect to see maxine vazquez
spend
i mean he's already spent a couple of
minutes but i expect this to be a
critical moment
he needs to maintain his best piece if
he can that black knight it's
ominously close to the white king if
he's forced to exchange that if not
if maxine bashley grabs things there's
nothing better to do than retreat that
night actually he has exchanged that
night
for white's bishop there suddenly um
he's lost a bit of momentum
suddenly black's pieces are much less
impressive than they were just two moves
ago
it's definitely i think very clever play
there from anish guri on the last couple
of turns
but i'm worried about his clock six
minutes ago i'm also worried about the
clock i'm also worried about that white
knight that is stranded on the edge of
the board you know
david calls them dim i say they fall off
the hedge you know and
just uh look at it it isn't real it
isn't very impressive there i mean i
really am worried about it
that it perhaps in order to escape well
a niche might have to
do some jumping around oh well okay
we're going to see
my favorite situation occur on the board
because
uh maximum ratio has castled his king to
the right side
and that has been promptly followed by a
porn storm i love this
yeah anishikari he only spent two
seconds on that move he was
ready he was thinking in maxine
bachelor's time um
and as ivanka mentions black's king is
finally committed itself to this right
side
it was playing the waiting game for so
long but black's king now has declared
its intentions and
anishieri with his last move showing he
wants to attack pushing this pawn
forward
this pawn is going to continue these two
pawns are going to act as battering rams
they're just going to try and break
black's defenses on that side
we're seeing exciting chess now max
invasion of grass meanwhile ignoring
that he's going to try and counter on
this
left side it's going to be a race whose
attack will be faster
i'm not sure i like anishikari's chances
it looks like these pawns are going to
break through
but maxine vashti graf he's so good in
these types of positions
when he sees the opponent's king um yeah
he just hones in on it
and nothing will stop him so um yeah
this one is exciting
it is super exciting we've chosen the
right game you know we have
a pawn race both sides are going to be
desperately opening lines for
attack because when you want to attack
you need to open up lines
especially for rook and the queen i
always call them the big guys
when the big guys come in and start
looking at your king you know that that
is
the game over and so yeah anish has been
forced to make a pawn move on the left
side of the board which isn't ideal but
he's done it just in order to just clog
things up over there because
he cannot allow a line to get open there
because that's it it will be almost game
over
yeah and it's normally not a not a good
idea to push pawns in front of your own
king you only create weaknesses
when that happens but this time it was
more important to just defend that white
knight on the edge of the board
and to block black's pawns on that left
side from pushing forward so
uh maximum vascular graft he's
temporarily been blocked off so he's
trying to use his queen the black queen
edging i mean it's a bit of a surprising
move for me it's edging out there to the
edge of the
uh to the side of the board maybe trying
to aim at that white knight
at some point but that white knight is
protected by white's pawn so a bit of a
mysterious move by vasheli graf i would
expect anishkiri to start pushing
forward again
on that right side it's time to just
kind of
go for it all right who do you think
will prevail this is the big thing
because we have a big race here
and indeed even the viewers at home
please tweet us who do you think is
going to win
maximum bachelor graph of anish giri
your hashtag
chess champs so david yeah um there we
go i think anish giri who's listening to
us
from his invisible studio at home he's
pushed his pawn again
on that right side this is the chest we
like to see this is what wesley so i
hope he's watching at home
getting inspired by um white pushing
there and now black
again playing on the left side playing
on the opposite flank just ignoring his
own king
black's trying to line up his two rooks
together now um
just lifting up his rook there two
squares he's going for it
he needs that line open he needs those
lines for that rook because you just
want the rook and the queens to align
one open line and that is it it's going
to be wonderful
now yeah i just i love this kind of pull
move it's very thematic
just to play that pawn forward just to
open one of those lines
and uh yeah is it also a little bit
brave it is very brave
and what you're seeing here is that a
maxim just seems to be
ignoring it wow it plays very quickly as
well so it seems to be kind of a
thematic oh but look at the bar now all
the way up to two
on the advantage on the bar yeah uh
maxine vachelagrav
is trying his best to defend here we see
that he's just brought his knight across
we say that a knight is a king's best
friend and nice is a great defender of
the king that's why maxine vazquez
played this
move but he's not closed down
any lines on that side we can see for
example if white chooses to capture this
pawn
or this pawn next move okay he's chosen
neither he's preparing that he's brought
his rook across
next move something will open up against
the black king
white will be able to open up this line
by capturing one of these two pawns he's
got choices
and suddenly these white rooks look how
beautiful they'll
they'll feel opposite this black king i
think this is
definitely turning against black right
now anish giri fortune favors the brave
he's going for it and he might be
rewarded
fantastic so we have some drama in this
game between two of the players who
really need to fight to qualify for the
quarterfinals they are
right now before this round outside the
top eight and we do see on on the bottom
here we
were following all the games and we can
see by the bars in most of the games
that really we have started off
with a lot of drama uh in the first
round of uh day three
yeah and about time too we've been
looking forward to this for a long time
and as kai mentions just below there
um we see the evaluations and in the
games between nakamura
and david anton and also between aronian
and hare krishna
white is doing very well the bar over
there on the left side
yes exciting and also in this game white
seems to be doing
oh i wish we could see anish geary's
face now we must be feeling confident
now
absolutely and we also have a lot of
excitement on twitter because
we've got a harry the age porn double
harry the h
paul has entered the game that's a tweet
from kevin
thomas and then we have harry and eric
he says
harry the age born just started to march
towards the king
big fans of that born yeah it's those
two white pawns on the right side there
we call them harry and gary because
they're on the h
and the g lines and those two brothers
they're doing all the work right now for
white
um i think they're going to crash
through and maxine vacherov that's why
he's thinking right now he's realizing
he's panicking a bit um it's very
difficult for black to even find a move
look at black's queen it's just offside
it's not helping all
i mean it's just can't take part in the
action on that other side of the board
when maxim now needs to think as well
he's been playing so fast entire game
but now
thinking for two minutes and now his
next move and there it is
yep maxine bachelor he continues his own
plan
he's lined up the black rooks on the
same line on the same file
but those black rooks they're staring at
a pawn that's defended so those black
rooks they look very nice they're
nice and pretty but they're not actually
doing anything right now meanwhile i
think it's time for nishkiri to try and
break through
and there we go he's opened up a line um
i think that's a great move he's opened
up a line towards the black king the
black king's forced to step forward
stepping closer towards the enemy army
um all white needs to do now is bring
more pieces into the attack
it's time to bring the queen in earth uh
the queen in or maybe that white knight
at the bottom of the board there bring
those towards the black king
checkmate we'll end the game i think in
this one yeah exactly no
we have this very nice expression in
chess that when you're attacking you
should invite
everyone to the party don't leave anyone
behind and i agree with david either the
queen or the knight needs to get
involved
and yeah then it will be curtains i
think for black it's already looking bad
and
the computer agrees it gives white a
three pawn advantage despite the fact
that it's equal material on the board
that's how strong white's attack will be
potentially and we see it white has
brought his knight
closer towards the black king that
knight was threatening a very dangerous
trek we see
with the knight coming towards the black
king this check
if blacker just played a random move
this check would have been decisive
attacking the king attacking the bishop
we call this a fork it's a type of
double attack and white would have won a
piece
instead black had to stop this knight
jumping forward but he's created more
weaknesses
this square is a big big hole in black's
position i think it's time to bring this
knight
again towards okay he's used the square
for the rook and he's going to be
putting his rook
into the enemy position next move he'll
line up these two rooks together
it's still great for white maybe there
was something even better last move
but i think anish guru he's still in
control
still in control but this is still very
hard to play it's not easy to find the
win here
no it's not easy to find because at the
minute the position is dynamically in
favor of
a niche you know it means that the
momentum is on his side
but he doesn't he isn't material up
which does
mean that but he has to be very accurate
and has to convert his advantage
into something tangible basically yeah
and maybe the only criticism we had of
anishigiri in the skilling open the last
championship event is that he did have a
couple of
perfect attacking positions and he
couldn't find the killer blow he traded
off the queen sometimes
he just couldn't finish things off so
he's built up a great position for white
here white has a big advantage
but will he find that way to break
through with less than four minutes on
his clock
this is the time for anish geary to
prove that he can
take it all the way to get that win that
he really really needs now to qualify
for quarter finals
and we do see that one game another game
has ended and hikaru nakamura has won
he's beaten david anton
and the american is now in seoul lead
with five and a half points
exciting yeah nakamura showing that
waking up at 6am
before 6am was not a factor yeah
nakamura when he's on fire can beat
anyone and
i think this unfortunately means that
david anton will be eliminated from the
competition because now he's lost three
games
and uh yeah that's a bad start for david
anton i don't think there's any way back
now uh we'll
we'll look at the equation afterwards
we'll look at the standings but yeah
that's that's a shame he's got so many
fans to ever dance one and such a
such a creative player but um
yeah up against the top guys in the
world it is hard yeah you have to
remember that there are no easy games
that this is an all play all where we
have the 12
best players most ferocious players in
the world battling out against each
other
and uh yeah normally when you're playing
a big open tournament you do badly
and you play weaker players now here
nope you got nakamura
yeah and imagine i mean david anton the
lowest seed he'll have been the name
that the other players have been
circling before the tournament they are
sharks these top players if they smell
blood if they see a weak link in the
tournament they'll be throwing
everything
at you and yeah they've just been taking
drawers against each other and putting
all of their energy into trying to play
him that's such a hard situation for him
not easy for david anton a great player
and a niche gear he's
very he's not looking too good on the
clock but he did make his move here
that's right so anish giri steps back
with his queen one square
i'm slightly surprised by that one um
yeah in general i don't like to retreat
when i'm on the uh offensive when i'm
trying to attack my opponent but
maybe white there he's just lining up
the queen and bishop on the same
diagonal
maybe the white queen is doing a kind of
multi-purpose job he's keeping an eye on
the left side he's keeping an eye on his
uh king's position but he's also going
to try and
um attack on the right later on um a bit
of a mysterious one by any girly but
he hasn't ruined anything he's just
playing uh playing nice and calmly
yeah i agree with you there david it
seems very mysterious to me i kind of
expected a different move to kind of try
to maintain the
momentum maybe a move with the knight
but as stepping back with the queen
and with the clock ticking i'm slightly
concerned
that he can't see a clear pan of
improvement
and uh now uh maxine bachelor graph has
done something that's kind of like i
call the cockroach approach
with the king you scuttling away from
danger
hiding beneath the floorboards
[Laughter]
that last move by uh maxine
vaschelagraph if we bring the board up
we can see the plan
by black earlier his king actually
started on the square it's back on its
starting square it scuttled across
earlier to the right side
now it's trying to run away it was being
attacked there he's going to try and run
away to the left side of the board
that black king is going on a journey
he's just trying to find a safe haven
but it's not clear where that's going to
be
um and andy's guillory now brings his
knight back towards the left maybe he's
anticipating maxine vasily grav he's
just mirroring
that black king whichever side the black
king goes he's gonna go into attack and
meanwhile maxine bachelor retreating his
queen here look at this battery
these three pieces lined up now against
one white pawn
the two rooks and the black queen yeah
no
definitely there's that looks very
impressive but uh i did
really like anish's last move where he
retreated the knight to the center
because he's like if the king is going
to go to the left
then i'm also going to go to left so i'm
expecting something to do with that
knight
i expect it to maneuver to another
square so that it can join in the attack
which is
on which is now on the king in the
center yeah and
um that's a quite a rare formation the
queen and the two rooks all on the same
line
eyeing up um eyeing up the same pawn i
think if the queen were
behind we would call that something uh
alekhine's gun but
here okay we've seen a sacrifice by
maxine vashey legrove
maxine giving up a rook there
for white's bishop that is a sacrifice a
rook is traditionally worth five points
at bishop worth three points so he's
giving up material but now black is
attacking the undefended white knight
on that left side of the board on the
edge of the board and anishiri
didn't even pause he gave up his own
rook for a night
so both sides sacrifice now and the pawn
structure
is wild both sides have weak pawns look
at that black bishop though that black
bishop is locked in
behind its own pawns it's on all of its
own pawns black's pawns are on dark
squares
so the black bishop is not good
meanwhile white is slowly
trying to improve his knight white's
knight is not impressive either it's
doing a defensive job
but imagine if that white knight gets to
the center later on
um i prefer white's position i agree
with you david i really like white's
position
i mean not only is it bad bishop but
look at that white
rook that is in the corner all it needs
to do is shift itself
one square and it's got a nice open line
to look at and
penetrate the black position so yeah i'm
loving it i really
also like the last move which is just to
kind of consolidate with that knight and
hold those very weak pawns that white
has together
and it's just looking really really nice
you know
none of pieces none of black's pieces
quite kind of makes sense
and of course that black king is so
unsafe
just look here just look at the air
around that king you know
yeah this black king is not safe imagine
if i could pick up this rook and put it
on a square like this eyeing up the
black king
if white could pick up this knight and
just put it on a square like this yeah
beautifully dominating the center of the
board
if white can achieve either of those
things one or the other then i think
white will have a winning advantage
meanwhile black has to deal with this
black bishop just look how bad it is
locked in behind its own pawns
it's just not doing anything we
mentioned it yesterday it's like a big
pawn
it's just not doing anything useful
right now he needs to grow up yes
he needs to find a path all right so
maximum vagina
now thinking for almost two minutes is
this simply what he's
thinking about how can i um get my
uh bishop into the action to maybe save
this position
definitely i think how to improve that
black bishop actually he's doing that by
trying to sacrifice a pawn
that is a trick though um he's putting a
pawn on the opposite collar of his
bishop which is a good thing it gives
the bishop more scope
but the black pawn would not uh white
should not have taken that
black one and instead we do see a trade
in the center there so a bit of relief
temporarily by maxine vasily grav
now he's lifting his rook up that black
rook's ready to swing across
um to the right side to try and block
off the white rook i think maxine
bachelor
his best hope here is to just survive
for the next few months try and trade
off the rooks we see that anish giri
we've seen it before he does
trade a few too many pieces sometimes
okay meanwhile
maxine vachelagrav bringing his rook
across i think it's time
for white to white to improve his knight
or improve his queen it's looking good
furniture
but two minutes on the clock now he
needs to speed up
he definitely does and he is very soon
going under those two minutes and we
ah we know he's been struggling so much
with getting these
winning positions all the way to that
win
he must be feeling quite nervous now i
wish i wish we could see him but
just being invisible there and it's uh
yeah exactly i have to say yeah we are
super excited about this game and also
twitter is also excited we have a tweet
from
jan sher khan who says this is the best
game i'm watching in this air things
champion chess
come on a niche you know and he's
certainly
keeping everyone entertained here what a
brilliant position
yeah i mean what a great game compared
to some of the others we've seen so far
this is
what we like to see exciting chess both
players going for it
um it does look like aneesh gary he's in
the driving seat but driver's seat and
okay he has sacrificed a pawn and
ishikiri i love that last move
um it might not have been the best
objectively maybe there were better ways
to just
keep a nice stable advantage but this
shows that anish giri he senses this is
the moment to gamble
he's only got a minute and a half left
he doesn't want to maintain the tension
instead he's going directly on the
attack if we bring up the analysis board
we can see why
white sacrificed this pawn why push this
pawn forward it's now it can be taken
in two separate ways um okay black's
taking it with the queen
if he'd taken it with the pawn we would
see white's knight jump to a beautiful
square
and start to attack some stuff instead
um
black captured with the queen white
recaptured with
with his own queen he took back upon now
he's very close
very very close to this black king he's
aiming towards it he's going to give
some checks maxine vacherov in the
meantime
trying to counter attack blackdown has a
huge threat to capture this pawn
it's only defended by the white king
right now and the black queen and black
brook creating threats of their own
both sides trying to attack trying to
get the enemy king who will be faster
yeah so it turns actors can't believe
it's so tense because you know you
mentioned that
maxine battlegroup has his own counter
threat which is actually deadly because
it can lead to checkmate
and they the black pieces aren't that
many of them but they are coordinating
very nicely
together and uh okay i really like what
anish has just
done now he has moved his queen and he's
moved it now so that the queen the black
queen can no longer defend
i have to take a different step but you
look at those pieces they're just all
huddled together
i was so nervous and excited a moment
ago oh look at the bar now
and yeah maxine vacheligraf he's moved
his bishop across one square
but white has many many options he could
bring his queen
to check the black king that queen would
be protected by the white rook another
option i think would be
very very strong for white would just be
to improve this night slowly
or maybe the best out of all of them
would be to bring this rook across one
square
bring it up to check this black king
either way white is on the attack
black's bishop has no targets it's just
doing a defensive job
white is the one in charge here but the
one move i just have to point out the
one move that you cannot play you cannot
get greedy and
try to snatch that pawn because if you
do that
then what's going to happen is that
black is also going to take a pawn and
once the king moves to the corner of the
board it looks like everything is good
right it does
it does look absolutely safe except
there is going to be a trick that we're
going to call the back rank mate
where the black queen gives herself up
and after
rook takes queen rick takes rook is
forced
and the king is just jammed in by his
own knight and pawn and cannot escape
that's right the king would be trapped
so black would sacrifice the queen there
and give checkmate
hanishkiri okay he doesn't fall into
that trap but anish he's playing a
defensive move that's not what we like
to see there
um if we catch up with the game position
he's just moved his rook across
defending this pawn that's it just feels
like white loses a bit of momentum here
um he should have spent that one move
that one tempo going for the attack
instead now white's rook is doing a
defensive job white's queen is doing a
defensive job
aneesh giri this is his tendency he'd
rather keep things together sometimes
rather than gamble and um will that come
back to bite him
maybe that'll be a small missed
opportunity for him especially with 40
seconds on the clock i think he's
getting nervous now
yeah far stronger moves there yeah
exactly in but about 40 seconds and each
gear only has 40 seconds
and maxine bachelor graph has just under
five minutes
this is a big time difference and i
agree with you david i think that's why
we're seeing him suddenly take a
cautious approach because
he didn't see a clear way through the
trees and instead
just thought okay fine i'll defend the
pawn not much time left this is kind of
an indicator of panic
no definite panic by any giri i think he
just wanted to make a move any move
and just quickly to make sure that he
stays over 30 seconds
but maybe under that invisibility cloak
he needed someone just whispering to him
attack attack attack because he had the
chance
but he is on well he did go slightly
passive there yeah
he does get every player get 10 seconds
for each move they make but
he's going to have to play very fast if
he's going to build up a lot of time
here
yeah and maxine vasily grav under four
minutes now
um and with a difficult position but um
he does have a moment of respect here
maximum vascular graft he's got a move
or two
to try and improve his forces yeah
thanks to anishigiri maybe not being as
direct as he should have been like one
move that i would be considering
immediately would be just
a way to trade off queens because when
your king is in huge danger
danger you need to trade off queens
because the queen is like the most
powerful attacker there is so i'm just
thinking if i
move my queen move the black queen all
the way up the board opposite
the white queen and then i can maybe
trade myself
off and escape the danger because this
black king is
a bad middle game king in the sense that
it's vulnerable to attack
but it's a fantastic piece for an
endgame because it's ready
to get going into an attack and start
munching pawns yeah this black king
if the queens leave the board the black
king is perfectly safe therefore
i think this is guaranteed that maxine
vachelagraph will find this move to try
and trade these queens
this is his best chance of survival if
he leaves the queens on the board
long-term white's queen and white's
knight they're the perfect attacking
combo
did not okay this he moved his bishop
instead and there we see the bar the
computer
agrees that that was not the best uh
move by black the bishop is better than
it
has been the whole game it's better than
it could have dreamt of just three or
four moves ago but
the black king is a bit open and now
white starts to improve his night the
white knight coming to try and munch on
the pawn
therefore maxine basil grav decides okay
now is the time he's trying to exchange
queens he's begging for that queen trade
yeah and will anish go for it i guess
that's what we're so excited to see now
isn't he still fighting to get this win
or will he
he has 13 seconds to decide and it's
such a techie second and he's decided
he's kept the queen's on the board and
that's what we like to see he's learned
from his mistakes from the last
tournament um he's keeping those queens
on the board but now black's king it's
been scurrying right it's going left
and now it goes back towards the corner
um
i still like white's position it's not
easy though especially with 20 seconds
and therefore
therefore anishikari decides to play a
defensive move that white rook steps up
one square
he's defending a pawn now on the left
defending a pawn in the center but i
really don't like black's last move
because uh you know anish played it very
safe i loved
what anish did because he liberated the
queen and now the queen can get going
into the attack
and uh yeah i think we've seen a blunder
by maxine rashford
he just missed that last queen check he
basically gave his opponent
gave any give a check for free and
unleashed gary he's picked off a pawn
he's won of pawn um white has a big big
advantage here
all that anishigiri has to do is make
sure that the white king stays safe
and therefore he trades the queens now
he does it after winning a pawn
anishigiri he should win this game black
has two pawns under attack right now
white is a pawn ahead everything's in in
each gear his favor apart from the clock
yes well we have uh dr dragonovsky on
twitter who says i really hope
gary converts this one i am feeling
happy for him yes
we also hope that anish uh actually gets
motoring i mean it's been a great game
but it would be very sad if anish didn't
actually
turn this one around yeah i mean if he
doesn't win this game at least he'll
only have himself to blame
he's done a perfect job so far it's just
about his finishing technique
there we see black defends one of his
pawns in the center but there's another
pawn
the black pawn on that left side it can
be captured white's knight can start
snacking on pawns
white's gonna have so many pawns pushing
forward on that left flank um okay
instead and she says no i'm not going to
allow any tricks i'm going to block your
pawn with my rook
note how all of white's pieces all of
white's pawns they're on white squares
they're all on light squares the
opposite color to black's bishop
therefore they can never ever be
captured they can never be targeted
yeah that's nice strategic ideas there
by anishigiri just it's good practical
play as well especially when low on time
put all your pieces on the opposite
squares to your opponent's bishop
yeah no i just like just look at the
magazine machine legra's last move
he retreated the bishop and the bishop
it was it was bad and then it was
suddenly became okay and then suddenly
it's gone back to being bad again
and it's just defending its own pawn
four seconds for an each geary there
three yeah you come home just make a
move
[Laughter]
look at those white pawns the white
pawns is running up the board black's
king meanwhile is also running
black's king was attacking the white
rook um this one it is
it is winning for white white has two
extra pawns and not just any pawns those
white pawns are extremely far advanced
they're going to get to the end of the
board one of them should become a queen
but maxine vashly grove as black he's
trying everything he can he's trying
every trick in the book that black rook
now attacking
a white horn um maxine vashgrove he's
clinging on for dear life he's setting
traps
he is the tricky frenchman but anishkari
he's now built up time he's up to almost
a minute again
he's improved his king he's improved his
pawns and ishiguri should
have this one in the bag now yeah
absolutely i agree with you there david
the king is just going to run and you
can see that maxine vachegrav is
desperately
piling his hopes on uh pinning his hopes
on this black pawn that he has
but why is that why it's connected past
pawns there's that duo that's so
powerful
that's right if we bring up the analysis
board these two pawns at the moment they
are going to decide the game
one of them will become a queen but
temporarily black has blocked them black
is controlling the advance of them with
this bishop
so it's time for anish geary to decide
okay do you try and get this pawn
running as well
long term or do you try and bring this
rook behind to try and help you push
these pawns
okay meanwhile anishiri i think he's
getting nervous again he just allowed
the black pawn to push
bit of a strange decision there um i
think
now is the moment there's a bit of
nerves jangling black is going to start
trying to create that race black also
has a strong pawn remember black's going
to try and bring his king
um into the position anishikari
therefore brings his knight back
keeping an eye on that black pawn this
is a critical moment i think anish giri
needs to find something a bit special in
order to maintain his advantage it's a
big advantage it's still a winning
advantage for white
but for a human it's not easy especially
with 50 seconds left on the clock
wow what are we looking for from manish
now what move are we looking for we see
the stock face
suggestion it is a huge advantage if he
does that rook move
yes and he's done it and he's done it
he's played it he has given
up his piece in order to clarify the
situation
and just bring his king and allow those
past pawns
to start running yeah black has a bishop
right now a bishop is normally worth
three point
uh three points but white has three very
strong pawns so those three pawns are
actually better than black's bishop
right now
black will have to give up his bishop
for those pawns and maximum
he's resigned early resignation maybe
we'll explain that a bit later but anish
giri
important win wow oh i so wish we could
see the invisible anishigiri's face now
that was such an important win for him
he's
he's back in it ivanka now yeah he's
definitely back in it he will he still
is in the danger zone but i still want
more victory to go
and he might be make it to the
quarterfinals
so yeah definitely a step in the right
direction and uh for
poor maxine bachelor yeah i don't know
yeah needs to get uh needs to win the
rest of his games
maximum version of now currently outside
uh still
top eight it's it's going to be tough
for him now with only two rounds to go
david
yeah maxi vacherov we kind of always
think of him as one of the best speed
players one of the best rapid players in
the world but
he's had a tough time that game was very
difficult for him andy gerry's played
fantastically
but yeah mvl now needs to well he needs
to throw everything at these next two
games
and you did mention at some point in
this game that it seemed like maxim
blundered i would love to to actually
see it out on the analysis board what
happened there
yes so maxime at some point um he looked
like he was just getting back into the
game
he was fighting back his king was
finally
finally getting into safety this black
king but now he made a huge mistake
rather than sidestep
again towards the corner uh where he'd
be very very safe
he moved his king forward one square
diagonally allowing a check
there was just no reason to allow this
check and now black realized he had to
lose a move his king did have to step
back
so black's basically given white this
move for free with the queen
and it was time for any guru to start
gobbling pawns and he's gary won a pawn
which he shouldn't have won um if
fashion had been a bit careful
now as well this queen is attacking two
key pawns so not only did
vascular grave lose a pawn it was one of
his most important pawns and a couple of
moves later the queens came off
anikuri is about to win a second pawn
two pawns are attacked he can't do
anything about that
and if we wear whiz ahead to the final
position the reason
that maxine rashford uh vacheriograph
resigned at the end here is because
these pawns are simply unstoppable if
black tries to gobble up one of them
another one will push this white pawn
will push forward it's
about to become a queen it's becoming a
lady in the next uh
next move so black has to give up his
bishop for this pawn and
this end game king porno games they are
tricky uh they're very difficult to
understand sometimes
but essentially white is going to run
with this one forward as soon as black
steps across with his king to stop this
pawn to keep an eye on this pawn
white is going to go the other way with
his king this pawn will act
as a distraction meanwhile white will
just step across slowly
gobble up this pawn and eventually white
will make another queen
with his remaining porn um very deep
stuff there but andi
saw it in advance and it's difficult for
maxine vegeta if he
suffered in that game yeah he definitely
suffered there
it's getting so tense in the
preliminaries of the air things monsters
with only two rounds to go and this
is the game that we will follow in the
next round magnus crossing
hikaru nakamura two big big rivals it's
going to be so interesting
all right it is getting so so tense now
we know with with a major
there's only 12 players only 11 rounds
of preliminaries
some players are really falling behind
here ivanka what's the mood like do you
think among the players now
well i think those people who have
secured the win secured a place like
hikaru nakamura he'll be very confident
i think he will just look to play
very rock solid but it's the mood will
be
super important for those players who
really need
to win there are seven players who need
to score two points out of two
and uh they will be psyching themselves
up pumping themselves listening to their
favorite music
trying to get going because you know
it's not po it is everything is possible
oh well you know and uh yeah we'll see
we'll see what they come up with
and we did see hikaru nakamura he did
get a win in that last game we know he's
now going to face magnus carlsen
magnus carlsen is not going to go easy
on him and play for that draw i guess
no that's right magnus knows that hikaru
later on in the tournament
might be his biggest rival so he would
be trying to knock him down right now
um also magnus has the white pieces he
never lets anyone off the hook he'll
like to squeeze his opponents to torture
them
and if he can get a win that'll be a
huge psychological battle
in their rivalry all right um
it's getting very tense there's only two
rounds left in the preliminaries
four players will leave us and a players
will go on to the quarter-finals so
i guess for some players who really need
to to get some wins now in the last
rounds
maybe they should put on some of their
motivational music
usually like uh drop and pop i mean my
favorite group
is maria a spanish group it gets me
more excited to go to the game the songs
change
at every tournament this is sort of my
ritual so there's gonna be one
one tournament one song that i will
obligatory
listen to uh just before going to the
game
right now i'm listening to bgs i like in
general pop songs you know like that i
mean i know they're not the best songs
but they're very catchy and some i
sometimes listen to rap too
like eminem although he doesn't have the
best songs either in terms of lyrics
playlist is called momentum the last
song that respect was atom some crystal
fighters
i'm not really like the the the men of
the music and stuff i just put sometimes
some some things but especially
mostly the rap things and so on they get
you in shape especially if the mood is
like so so and you need to fight
people rajamou into the rap songs we've
talked about this before
you're like can you agree with teamwork
don't you yeah you've got to have some
rap songs so you know some anger in
there
wesley's oils who said that didn't he
eminem you agree with that don't you
yeah of course
and david we know you're a motivational
song that's right
um it's a song from mulan i'll make a
man out of you but sometimes i'm in
more of a kind of despacito mood mm-hmm
well i'm not gonna dance
so is this basically is this the time
now for players if they
if they need to get pumped up to put on
that motivational music with only two
rounds to go
yeah absolutely you know if every
victory counts here
four players will be eliminated this is
the moment where you do
anything you change into your lucky
shirt you have a cold shower
anything put on your motivational music
and
sit down and get ready with your mouse
what do you think the players are doing
now david
um a lot of the games lasted for quite a
long time they haven't had too much time
to prepare for the next one or is that
what it's all about actually i think if
the players are
sensible if they're being practical they
won't be looking at too much chest in
this break
it's more it's going to be more about
inspiration more about who can deal with
those really tense emotional
dramatic moments better and i think just
staring at a chessboard now
this preparation should have been done
earlier it's all about getting fresh
getting focused
um i didn't i don't think we saw it in
this game but we did see yesterday the
on passant there are some special moves
in chess right
yes and uh david he's giving us some
chess lessons and
today's theme is about those special
moves
[Music]
there are some special moves in chess
which go against the normal rules
you can normally only do these once
again castling
involves the king and the rooks if there
is nothing between the king and the
rooks
and if they haven't moved so far in the
game then the king
and castle which means moving the king
across two squares
and the rook jumps over this would be
castling on the king side
and likewise you can also castle on the
other side the king
also goes two squares across and the
rook jumps over
you cannot castle if you're already in
check though and you cannot castle
through check
i recommend doing this in every game it
keeps your king nice and safe
another special move is on passant this
means when one side has a pawn on their
fifth rank
if the opponent's pawn tries to move two
squares to bypass it
it can actually be captured as if it
just moved one square
ompasson is one of the trickiest moves
in chess and it's also one of the newest
additions
to the rules it only came into effect
about 300 to 400 years ago
promotion is a special move in chess
when your pawn gets to the end of the
board
to your opponent's side it can become a
queen
a brook a bishop or a knight so for
example
you would push the pawn forward you
would replace it now with a queen
[Music]
yes there we have it yeah that's the
first time i've seen it
hopefully that's useful for the people
at home as well definitely the ampa song
the castling
well we always talk about the castling
of course and uh it's nice to get these
uh chess lessons from you david i'm
trying to learn thank you and also
actually on the champions chess tour
website there's now a new feature called
learn chess so if you're just getting to
grips with the games if you're just
wanting to learn about on password about
castling about some of these other
special moves then
go check it out there's lots of some
very well i think useful animations
there
now we are excited to see um after a
while here the standings
after nine rounds um in the
preliminaries only two rounds remain but
actually
there is still a game going on and
that's why the standix isn't ready yet
because
alexander grishard magnus carlsen is
still
playing that ninth round game but right
now before that is done
hikaru nakamura is in sole lead with
five and a half points
and right now the players that are not
qualified for the quarterfinals are
alexander grishock pentala harry krishna
maxim vajialagrav
and david anton so maybe that's why
alexander krishik is
staying in this game for so long he
knows he needs to win and here we have
the game between the two
yeah and actually it's magnus carlsen as
we've seen so many times
torturing his opponent magnus carson as
black has an extra pawn
black has two pawns white only has one
and each side has a rook
um this one magnus carson he's already
been pushing for 30 moves
in a very similar position trying to win
that last white pawn
but alexander grisham is defending
resolutely um he's clinging on to dear
life he knows that
as white he needs to save this game to
have a chance of qualifying for the
knockouts
all right and is this it's they're just
simply waiting for that draw just
trying to get the other person to
blunder yeah more or less that's what
magnus is doing he's just making random
moves he's just
slowly moving the rook one side of the
board another side checking
making the gristich play awkward moves
and it's just about trying to catch
awkward um uh grisha with a basically a
blunder
you know just hoping that he will crack
that's right with best play
i think if with ideal play this should
be a draw but there's so many traps so
many tricks
look at black's king deep in the enemy
camp um black's king as well is very
close to that white pawn white rook
has to stay passive defending it this
one is very difficult for gristrok to
defend
it should be a draw but magnus he will
try and squeeze water from a stone we've
seen it
we've seen him do it before against
daniel dubov winning a pawn up
even though the game should be a draw
magnus carlsen he loves these scenarios
where there's no risk
he could just slowly put the pressure on
his opponent
all right well it's typical magnus isn't
it you just
try just a little bit longer and
everyone else would just be nah this is
a girl
yeah yeah because i think he's got such
a strong nervous constitution that he
can handle this type of thing
and uh his opponents are not actually to
be honest
his opponents are not used to being
tested in this way as well
because i know most people would have
perhaps packed up and said a draw
many many moves ago but uh yeah magnus
carrying on
yeah i mean i i hope wesley sews
watching this game as well just learning
from this perseverance
that's what separates magnus carlsen
from the rest he
that's why he's the world champion he
pushes every advantage he takes
every chance he gets um here he's played
with i mean we're almost on move 100.
wesley so takes all these draws after 10
moves
i mean i'd love to see a tiebreaker for
example with
number of moves played magnus carlsen
racking up the moves
giving us all the entertainment we can
ask for um
yeah love to see it yeah and uh but do
you think grishik can
hold the draw so gristruck he needs to
cling on
actually not much longer now the last
pawn move
the last capture was on move 53 and
there's a rule in chess that after 50
moves
without a capture or report move the
game is declared drawn
so seven more moves um grystrok needs to
survive
just to uh secure the draw here magnus
carlsen he has only seven moves left to
win
white's remaining pawn or he needs to
trade a set of pawns in the next seven
moves
otherwise the game will immediately be
declared drawn hmm
and alexander grishock he's only 21
seconds on the clock
this is what we're used to with
alexander grisham right he's it seems
like he goes from 15 minutes to just
less than a minute and in two minutes
he's probably been playing with 20
seconds on the clock for the last 90
moves
um yeah that's classic uh classic
grishik and that must mean that
he is during the game taking some really
long pauses do you think what is it like
to playing against him
yeah i've been lucky i've played against
him and it's intimidating he's having
these long long things sometimes in the
opening and you just
you just know he's coming up with a deep
concept um that being said if you can
survive into the end game survive till
later
uh in the game against him you will get
a chance or two he won't play perfect
chess every time because he's always
low on the clock and uh maybe that's
just what what's held him back from
becoming world champion himself
ah yeah because he is one of the older
one of the more experienced uh guys in
the game here the experience
the russian alexander grishock and and
played magnus
so many times i guess yeah yeah he has
this yes
yes and and of course you have to
remember he was three-time world blitz
champion so he's a
super ferocious dangerous player but uh
here i think he can
hold the draw he's also pretty used to
playing with no time on the clock
and you can just look at both those
players they're super focused
there's no nerves whatsoever in
grishak's face yeah and
just above the board there above the bar
above the players we see the move number
we're on move
99 now that moves
four moves without a trade or a capture
and then uh
yeah if the player if nothing happens if
there are no trades captures before
move 103 the game is immediately a draw
they will have played 50 moves without
anything happening well without any
pieces leaving the board so we're
getting closer only three more moves
left after this one
by magnus carlsen 99 but they don't have
99 problems
seems quite easy doesn't it and there we
are move 100 move 100.
three more moves yeah and another player
in this tournament harry krishna i
mentioned this yesterday i once played a
game
against him which lasted 236 moves
that was a long one we should also
mention that
um usually all the games start at top of
the hour
but obviously this game is still going
on so it will be a 10 minute break
for both of these players before they
start their round number 10.
and magnus carson once again trying to
win that white pawn but he's only got
two moves left to win that white pawn
imagine how depressing it will be he
gets so close he's only one move away
from winning it
and then suddenly the game is a draw
with the 50 move rule but
um yeah alexander grisham defending
perfectly black's problem is if he does
capture the white pawn which he might
well do
um then he will also lose one of his own
pawns
we might actually see that happen i
think it will happen right now magnus
carson
on move 103. he did capture that pawn
so we've got another 50 moves left at
least
magnus he will have known that that
would be the uh the drawing move that he
was about to hit the time limit
um well about to hit the move limit um
before a draw so that's why he made that
capture
does that then automatically happen on
the computer the computer just said oh
now it's a draw you
do yes with with online chess um that's
exactly what happens every time you
repeat the position three times this
little bar comes up and goes well you
finished
the game is we've been repeated three
times all the same here with the 50 move
rule um and over the board chess is a
little bit more complicated you have to
actually keep
notes you have to claim in a special way
and so that's what that's
one of the many things why i like online
chess
i've actually played one of the world's
top 10 players and he
misclaimed against me he uh he thought
it was 50 moves but he'd miscounted
unfortunately it was 50 moves a few
weeks later but
um yeah it's tricky keeping a note uh
when you write down the moves
but that's another beauty of online
chess it's automatically done for you
so they are still sitting here playing
and everyone
you are saying the computer is saying
this is just a dead road does the
players and
and i'll ask you as well david is
sometimes annoying with magnus that he
just
doesn't give up when everyone's like
come on it's a draw
and i mean as a chess fan i love to see
him try and squeeze out these small
advantages
sometimes it does work and sometimes he
does win when you're playing against him
though it's just torture
um i mean he is a sadist he likes to see
but you we do see the reason it is a
draw despite black's extra pawn
is that that pawn will not get to its
goal white white's king will start
blocking that pawn
and the rooks will just balance each
other out so um i would expect to see
here for example white's king yep
shuffle across to the corner um black is
very close to giving checkmate if
black's rook could somehow swing around
to give check on the bottom rank there
on the bottom row that would be
checkmate but as soon as black's king
as soon as black's rook sorry leaves the
same line as its king white will start
giving check from behind
so there's just no way to make progress
here and still he is
trying magnus carlsen yeah i don't think
he'll try for much longer and
there you see it um do you do you think
uh
grishik will have a sense of humor and
throw in a check
grystry here he could capture that white
poor that black pawn with his rook
right now and that would be an immediate
draw or as ivanka
wants to show he could have forced a
stalemate um but okay instead we'll see
king versus king and the draw
it is a draw after well one hour and
five minutes that game lasted wow and uh
they're both sitting there looking at
the
i guess magnus is disappointed sitting
here for this long it must mean he's
he really was going for the win in this
game yeah
he he certainly did try his uh his luck
and he pushed it as far as he can go and
i i for one
i really like to see this happen
actually i really like to see
top grand masters being put under
pressure and
magnus carlsen gives us hope that
absolutely everyone can go wrong
so i just love that he did this and they
do now have 10 minutes before they start
their next round
round 10 which means there's only two
rounds
left now and magnus well he's
quite comfortable on the table now but
it is actually hikaru nakamura in seoul
lead and hikaru nakamura
is the next player that magnus carlton
will face what do you think he's
thinking about sitting here now is it
what just happened or is it
looking forward to what's going to
happen well we saw nakamura earlier
laugh
laughing in his chair i reckon he would
have been laughing while watching that
one too
but now it's time to get focused again
and black against magnus carlton it's
the hardest pairing it's the hottest
game in chess
nakamura he'll have spent a bit of that
time just relaxing but also a bit of
time preparing thinking about what
opening he's going for what strategy
he's going for
all right so it is finally time to look
at the results from round
nine and uh we finally we did have quite
a few wins
uh on each gear as we saw he beat
maximum majesty such an important win
for
the dutchman and then also hikaru
nakamura he got a win against david
anton meaning that david anton
most likely are almost 100 certain is
out of the air things monsters
live on aronian pentahory krishna that
was withdrawal jana pomnyacci beat his
fellow russian daniel dubois very
interesting game there
and then alexander grishok magnus
carlsen after
one hour and five minutes played to a
draw and wesley saw and timora jabo on
the other hand after only four minutes
played jojo so that means wesley so had
a very long time to think now
okay we are getting ready for round nine
it's time to
shake it off the players are playing
fantastic chess i'm not a great chess
player but i am learning and you can
watch me as i try to get a little bit
better
we are doing pins now i did have a
little bit of trouble with the double
attack so
pinning i like that better oh it's
pinning the rook
ah okay yay
well pinning i'm doing good with the
pinning
cross pin cross pin okay uh
well ah okay yes
because i if i move it here well he
cannot take because
i will just go for the black rook
yes okay painting is my thing in chess
pinning i love it so how about if my
i'm on my rook here she cannot move
it must be this move because the queen
cannot move
i will just take a rook
and now
oh oh my gosh
i see it okay i'm not even gonna comment
on that
wow okay well i found it
after a while it was staring right into
my face i could obviously just take the
queen
ah well actually i think i did good with
a pinning
only that one very embarrassing not
seeing
the point could take the queen all right
i've actually just been dreading showing
you guys this one because
they were quite nice to me when editing
this i spent like
a minute before i saw that that i could
just take that queen
is that is that just typical with
beginners we just don't see the obvious
moves maybe to start off with yes it
does take a little bit of time but you
know once you see the pattern maybe
three times that's it
you know you it's there in your brain
and you won't forget it
yeah we always say look for checks and
captures first in every position now
you've
definitely learned that yeah you'll
never forget to always look for those
techniques
all right you did well though oh thank
you again they are
quite nice to me when editing this i'm
spending a lot of time and
i'm getting so stressed with the clock i
can definitely see why playing
fast rapid chess and blisters is so much
harder it's just so much easier to
forget
and forget things yeah definitely when
the heart is racing it's hard for the
brain to work properly yeah
um have you found it useful with the
chesapeal challenge i definitely i
definitely have i definitely have i
definitely am learning and pins and
forks
i think those maybe are my favorite to
actually look for the pins and fork
i think he's winning just yeah those
little expressions but i'm pretty sure
that
now you know about it you know now you
know it you know it
exactly all right well i'm learning
chess that the players in there thanks
monsters they are playing fantastic
chess i think they are i think today is
so much more interesting they're
actually going for those wins
yeah they have they're playing very
adventurous chess i mean it's just what
we came here to see we wanted to see
blood
we wanted to see adventure we want to
see attacks and we've been rewarded with
some decisive games
and that's just brilliant definitely and
it's time to actually look at the
standings after
nine rounds with two rounds to go and we
now see
kikaru nakamura is in so lead with
five and a half points and then we have
five players
on five points two players on four and a
half points
and then we see that the bottom form
there right now are not
qualified for the quarterfinals in
ishikiri pentlahar krishna within bashir
and david anton okay who needs to start
fighting now david who are you excited
to to keep an eye on
i think maxine vasily graf now and annie
shakiri
pentana herrera christian as well all of
them need to win unfortunately david
anton at the bottom is probably out now
but the others maxine vascular graft he
needs to win both of his games and hope
that the tiebreaks favor him
anishikari probably with his great
tiebreak scores
uh his number of wins another win will
be enough
um to launch him into those top eight
places hare krishna as well
needs to win this next game against
wesley so what do you think the players
on five points there
are thinking and what what is their
mentality like now jamaica
i think the players and five points can
cannot either
they can't rest as well because you know
you know they have one bad result and
that's it they're already down in the
danger zone
so they need to play solid they need to
take it easy
and they need to be consistent um but
it's really all about those players at
the bottom
whether they can whip up those while
we're in the attacks
all right well it is time to look at the
games that will be played in round
number 10. we have maximum vagiela grab
your bank i mentioned
the players in bottom they need to win
and maximum magilogram is one of those
players
he is facing timor rajab david
do you think max and rachel will just
with white pieces or go for that win
yeah i think it's now or never for
maxime and with white he's extremely
good
yeah i think he'll gamble everything on
this game and then we have in the next
game it's pencilla hare krishna he is
facing
wesley so pantalary krishna needs a win
do you think wesley saw will just take
this to a draw
well it's going to be like the immovable
energy basis we're not having to go
again but uh
uh unstoppable force against the
immovable object
and that's what i'm expecting from those
i think wesley would be
ultra solid and i feel a bit sorry for
harry krishna because he had the white
pieces against someone
and it is wesley and wesley has been the
most solid player
in the tournament so far so he seems
unbeatable definitely does and then
in the next game a player that hasn't
been unbeatable danielle dubo he just
lost against jana pognati and now he's
facing levonoronian who seemed
so so focused and so solid david yeah
that's such a tough pairing imagine
coming off a loss you want things to be
easier and you're playing love on
aronian
dubov he can't lose again with white
it's tough for him does he go for the
win and risk everything
risk dropping out of those uh
qualification places does he try and beg
for a draw and hope that he survives in
the final round as well
he's in a tough situation next game is
david anton he is playing against jan
no pognation david anton most likely or
definitely is out of the competition
ivanka
what will this game look like well i
think uh david anton has nothing to lose
he knows he's out so he might as well
have fun
and enjoy the game and just throw the
kitchen sink at nepalniachi
and then we have that the next game is
between anish giri and
alexander grishock geary also getting a
long pause here because grishard's game
lasted for so long
gear you won his last game has the
turning point come for a niche gary now
david it might well have done and he's
got the white
pieces again for the second game in a
row this is the moment he needs
uh he's just like maximum graph he's
going to gamble everything on this game
we've heard anishkari say it before he's
feeling good feeling confident
he's going to go for the win and then
the game that we will follow
obviously because it is the game between
the two big rivals magnus carlsen
and hikaru nakamura and magnus carlson
played such a long game now david
hikaru nakamura he is coming from a win
he is in seoul
lead is magnus carlsen is this the game
he's been looking for the one he really
wants to win
i think he'll just try and put one over
his old rival we see there
the stats this is just speed chess this
is just rapid and blitz chess they've
played each other so many times um
imagine with classical as well that's
hundreds of times they've played each
other
magnus carlsen is in the ascendancy he
scored many more wins
than nakamura but he'll try and do that
again
he's got the white pieces well ladies
and gentlemen we are getting ready for
round number 10 of 11. it is
getting so 10 so many players need to
fight for wins to actually
qualify for the quarter-finals five
players
will leave us after today eight will go
on to quarter finals and it is magnus
carlsen
versus his big big rival hikaru nakamura
in this game
i'm really looking forward to this one i
actually saw this game coming from
before we started this is one game that
i'm really looking forward to yeah this
would be a dream final let alone
um a preliminary round game and um yeah
magnus carson he has
opened with his kingspawn nakamura as
black
replying we do see an opening that we
call the spanish we've seen it many
times before
in this tournament um okay
nakamura playing an opening called the
berlin wall the berlin defense
it's because it's so so solid as black
as
as yeah as black you're just aiming for
the draw maybe
um with white it's hard to break down
this berlin wall it's hard to create
many winning chances so
very solid start by both players um we
do see a pair of pawns have left the
board and now a set of knights have left
the board white's rook there
in the middle of the board it will be
will be forced to retreat
um sooner rather than later black's
knight heading to the back rank
um very very balanced so far a
symmetrical pawn structure almost
same complement of pieces as well
remaining
magnus taking a pause here okay he
retreats his rook
we have seen magnus castle play this
before in the champions chess tour
to make a draw as white against wesley
so so my only concern with this start
with this opening is that we might see
uh we might see things
fizzle out quite quickly nakamura looks
very calm
meanwhile he's seen this all before he's
going to um
wait and decide in fact the two players
are actually repeating a line that they
played
against themselves in 2019 so
here we go bishop f4 bishop moves out
and yes so in that game
hikaru offered a trade of dark squared
bishops
that's right and i've actually had this
position myself before as white
only once but it was against the
artificial intelligence program
alpha zero and i use this opening as
white to make a draw
it's foolproof you give black no winning
chances
it's completely balanced no risk at all
um
that being said it's not very ambitious
either it's hard to create winning
chances as white so
it does look like magnus carlsen in this
game is probably just happy to get
one step closer to qualification well we
have a new move though
with that queen coming out that is new
that's only ever been played once before
so okay there's been some change i don't
think i agree with you i think uh magnus
hasn't chosen the most aggressive line
to say the least yes but okay you know
perhaps he's saying look i can play
anything here
and yeah maybe some mind games going on
as well they've repeated
for 12 moves they've repeated pretty
much the same opening they've played
before
now magnus carlsen playing something a
bit different asking hikaru nakamura
have you done your homework have you
looked at this move this new move
with his last move white is bringing his
queen out and defending the bishop in
front of it
i do expect to see a trade of bishops
though nakamura has a lot of choice here
yeah i think very balanced so far slow
start for for the two rivals
hikaru nakamura coming from a win in his
last game and he
he obviously is feeling very confident
that he will qualify now with five and a
half points
yeah even with a couple of losses he
probably will still make it
um that being said of course he doesn't
want to lose a game he gets his big
rival
lose a bit of face there um yeah these
guys they're very proud and they want to
squeeze every point yes well one thing
we have to say i kind of mention is that
the placings in the preliminaries
actually affect whether you
have whether you can choose white or
black in the armageddon games if it gets
that far
so there is and you also get to choose
the colors that you start off with
so there's like some small advantages i
think um
i agree with you though i do think that
magnus
will definitely try for something just
for the kind of moral victory he can't
live
because he can't deliver exactly
yeah and i think it not only determines
who can choose the armageddon
colours so the the colours in the
tiebreak games
um it also chooses uh it also determines
the seeding
so whoever finishes in first place um in
these preliminaries they'll play whoever
finishes in eighth place so you might
get slightly easier pairing
in the quarter-finals if you top the
table
in this preliminary stage so um at the
moment that's nakamura he's at the top
of the table and he will be
very happy with the draw here that's why
he's trying to trade off pieces we see a
pair of bishops
leave the board there i think nakamura
he'll either improve his night
right now or who he might offer a trade
of queens he does offer a trade of
queens
um magnus carson with a big decision
here do you run away
with your queen or do you allow the swap
if he allows the swap is
is that a clear sign that magnus
actually also is happy with the draw
here
yes yes absolutely
but it's still very exciting to watch
these two great legends play
chess and we have a tweet from chad who
says nothing like getting up on the
first day of holiday time off
and watching magnus vs hikaru exciting
definitely well let's see then it is
exciting now to
keep an eye on that white queen will it
trade itself off
or is he going to fight here yeah
big moment let's hope that chad is
blessed with
a long fighting game i'm not overly
optimistic unfortunately i do think
magnus will be
tempted okay he does keep the queens on
the board he's kept the queens on the
board
and so so there is some a choice for
some life
the only thing that concerns me is that
the structure of the pawns is a little
bit too symmetrical for my taste
you know it's difficult to kind of get
an advantage when the
position is so simple like this and
now hikaru has developed the bishop to
attack the queen
and the queen has sliced up so now now
it's magnus offering a trade
yeah so magnus he avoided those queens
coming off the board just two moves ago
now he's saying okay you proved yourself
now we can trade queens
um and the problem right now is that as
iran mentioned all of the pawns i mean
the ports have just been playing copycat
and they're
all completely balanced there's no
chance of creating a pass pawn that's
one way to win the game when you can't
go for checkmate to get a pawn to the
end of the board make a new queen
um this i mean that would just not
happen in this game
all the pawns are pretty much blocked we
do see white have a set of double pawns
now
there's that last capture white
recaptured the queen
white's pawns are doubled on that g line
we see the g below the board
those pawns are doubled but they're not
a big weakness white's three pawns on
the right side
they do defend each other right now yeah
i was just looking at the air things
stats we can see once again
everything is quite perfect for magnus
carlsen except
the temperature is too high what a
what a lovely such a hard life when
we're in a warm country and
temperature's just too high yeah we're
not feeling sorry for him are we
no we are not now and we don't actually
we we can't see the air quality for
hikaru nakamura
we know that he's not sitting at home is
he he had to switch locations right
before the start of the tournament
that's right just on the eve of the
tournament
um there was a bit of a last-minute
dilemma
the facility his office his office space
the whole building had to be evacuated
there was a covid scare
he had to set up everything last minute
at home and um
yeah he's playing from an unfamiliar
location so
it hasn't affected him though he's doing
well so far this time definitely maybe
this should be his new
facility for playing um we do have a lot
of moves that's right and
um unfortunately no key moves the queens
have been traded
um we do see the rooks in the middle
there there's one open line in the
position
and those rooks are staring at each
other we're likely to see those rooks
leave the board
a bit later on meanwhile magnus carson
bringing his king closer to the center
and
if anyone i would slightly to prefer to
be white white's pawns
slightly further advanced on that right
side means he has a tiny bit more space
normally space isn't such an issue when
lots of pieces are leaving the board
um you want x you want your pawns
further advanced forward
if you have lots of pieces it gives them
more room to maneuver behind those pawns
here all the pieces are leaving the
board and actually magnus carson's last
move i thought he was going to trade
rooks
but no he brings his rook across two
squares
yes bit of a mysterious one well one
thing that we have seen from
magnus's games is that he's been an
endgame virtuoso
he's managed to magic all sorts of
winning positions from what seemingly
looks like
thin air so do you think he can do it
and in fact this is a question to
everyone at home
you can tweet the response or using the
hashtag chess champs do you think magnus
can
manage to win this game and uh put
hikaru in his place
yeah i i'm not a betting man
i'm not sure what i would say here
you're right magnus
he almost squeezed that one out against
alexandria grisham he almost got the win
there he did win yesterday against
daniel dubov in a very tencent game
yeah um that'll be a huge victory today
if he does manage it and
we do see i mentioned that space he's
just trying to push his pawns forward
um maybe if later if all the pieces
leave the board
having your pawns further advance
forward it might help in a race to dart
towards the end of the board and make a
new queen
because one of the things that i know
about this type of position is that um
the energy so when you have lots of
central tension with pawns or so in the
center there's a lot of energy in there
but once that energy has gone
exactly like in this position when
there's the pawns are not in conflict
with each other
everything has to divert to the wings
and tom becomes a story about who can
take the most space
who can put their pieces in the better
squares and you can actually see with
this last two moves that
magnus has got a knight right in
hikaru's side of the board
so it's there it's in a good spot
and this mysterious rook can perhaps
have some use
yeah um nakamura meanwhile retreating
his bishop to its start square
that's a very passive move he's
basically saying to magnus okay
i'm solid it's the onus is on you to try
and move forward
and beat me and actually magnus's last
move he is
playing for the win he is going to try
wow and get the advantage here this last
move with the white pawn he's supporting
an advance
of the other pawn so for example if
black just moves his king towards the
center while he's going to push forward
he's going to try and open things up
for his rook along this line if we do
see some trades
then maybe the fact that white's
advanced pawn
i mean maybe just the fact that it's so
far into the enemy position it's in
black's half now
maybe this will be a big factor later it
will try and dart towards
its promotion square i just think if
magnus carson plays this move next turn
we will see things start to liven up and
he will be going for the win
he's also three minutes on the clock
yeah okay interesting to see if that
move
will appear and we did see the bar shift
i mean it's not
any crisis for hikaru nakamura but it
does say
0.6 for magnus carlsen and is this
suddenly
a lot more interesting than just a few
moves ago yeah i think it's it's you
know but the position by itself
is probably quite solid and quite safe
but it's just the attitude
of the players that we know that they
are going to fight it out and that kind
of makes a little bit more exciting
because
this is what we want to see we want to
see these small little plans that
that magnus has you know just to cause
hikaru
some problems and i i really like in
watching this type of chess because it's
very very intelligent very subtle
and when you see it done and then you
can kind of like retrospectively
apply logic to it it becomes like oh
yeah
so that's how you get good at endgames
yeah and talking of retrospectively
looking at things i just feel over the
last five six moves
white has improved his position he's
pushed his pawn up the board he's now
preparing
another pawn advance and the white king
is slightly more centralized than the
black king magnus he's been playing with
a plan
over the last five six moves it feels
like nakamura he's just been moving his
pieces around not necessarily improving
them
the black king is still in the corner
not really doing too much
um it feels like nakamura maybe relaxed
a bit too early he thought that
uh he thought magnus just wanted to draw
with his opening nakamura he relaxed
suddenly that's why he's thinking there
that's why he had a long think
he realized okay i can't just sit here
and do nothing magnus will try and beat
me
and we see it on the clock as well after
uh 27 moves
magnus carlsen had more time on his
clock than when he started
hikaru nakamura has spent some time okay
what's happening yeah and magnus has
played that move we were hoping for
things are going to liven up a set of
pawns will be traded in the middle and
suddenly i love white's position um he's
aiming to
remove black's most central pawn um just
so he has a bit more control
and control over the center yeah i can
see you liking this position david
because whenever i see pawns like
dominating your
opponent's pieces i think of david i
remember david saying the pawns should
be dominating their pieces so let's look
at that pawn
on the right side of the board the
furthest one that's advanced
it's kind of controlling black's bishop
that lies
all the way on the left side of the
board that bishop really can't move to
many places
and now there's conflict in the center
as well so hikaru always has to be
thinking about
that conflict there and yeah there's
just so much purpose in
magnus's position that's right
especially that white knight as well
um as your vancouver mentions that black
bishop has just dominated and
meanwhile hikaru kind of frowned a bit
there he was just
it doesn't look like he's entirely happy
with this position he knows he's not
losing
black is still extremely solid um still
the same number of pieces
still roughly balanced but magnus is the
one putting the pressure on and
that's why we're seeing hikaru nakamura
normally so quick and confident he is
burning time on the clock now
could that could that become a big
factor here now actually
that hikaru is just spending so much
time
quite possibly um it is quite simple i
mean the position is
simplified queensland left the board
lots of other pieces of left the board
so the clock won't be the decisive
factor but if
he starts ticking down under five
minutes if he's still under a bit of
kind of strategic pressure from magnus
carson if magnus is still setting those
traps
um improving his pieces hikaru he'll
start to feel slightly more nervous and
that could build up
i've been there many times when these
top players these top 10 players
they apply the pressure and it's never
never fun
well one of the things that must be also
disconcerting when it comes to the clock
is that here magnus has actually got
more time
now than when he started
[Laughter]
and there's a little bit of pride there
and you kind of can get a little bit
embarrassed by the fact that your
opponent is just blitzing up the moves
and is able to get a good position like
that yeah
actually around 10 years ago i played
hikaru nakamura and
um i was black he played 42 moves
in this is a long game a classical game
so he each had about two hours for the
first 40 moves then would gain another
hour
he played the first 42 moves instantly
he didn't pause to think at all
wow and he told me afterwards he studied
that exact position at home after 42
moves
and because after mu 40 we gained an
extra hour on the clock
he'd actually had nearly three hours on
his clock left and meanwhile i was done
one minute
it was a miracle it was by the skin of
my teeth i had to
sacrifice my queen to build a fortress
um but yeah that's how well prepared
these players are how confident they can
be
and talking of confidence nakamura he's
pushing a pawn forward
he's traded off a set of pawns on that
right side now he's
trying as well to get those bishops off
um
yeah that's a very confident move by
nakamura i would have hesitated i would
have thought oh maybe i'm creating
weaknesses
but he's not afraid to go for it and he
knows that if bishops leave the board
he'll be
inching closer to that desired result to
get the draw
so what can sort of what is magnus's
plan
here because you're saying it it's sort
of the feeling that maybe he is playing
for the win here now
what could be his plan yeah so if we
bring up the board we can
see the two things magnus carlsen is
considering here he's debating
does he exchange these bishops does he
allow the bishops to leave the board
but suddenly maybe his central pawns
will become a bit weak
black's knight attacking this undefended
pawn right now
the other thing magnus carlsen is
considering is keeping these bishops
does he retreat his bishop it might look
like a passive square this white bishop
doing not much right now
but he's keeping pieces on the board and
having more pieces on the board
favors you if you have more space and
the reason why has more space is his
pawns are slightly further advanced
well he's done that he's retreated his
bishop but he treated it one square
and uh hikari responded immediately by
advancing the pawn on the right side of
the board
and it's all very tense here because i
think he did that to stop
white from taking even more space with
that pawn on the right side
so yeah yeah you see the players again
when in doubt they're just slowly edging
forward
um black's pawn taking more space but
also inching towards its promotion
square if that black pawn
on the right there if it does get to the
end will make a new queen
magnus he won't allow that but one thing
i've learned about end games especially
when knights are on the board
knights struggle against these corner
pawns so if you imagine the bishops
leaving the ward the rook's leaving the
board the fact that hikaru nakamura he's
starting to push his corner pawn
that might be a big factor later on yeah
and one thing that i've kind of realized
about these endings
is that you should never rush with your
plan you know because
yes you white has a plan of just maybe
advancing the pawn on the right side
one two two squares forward just to
attack the bishop but you shouldn't
really do that you should just
kind of keep your options open keep your
opponent guessing as to what you're
gonna do
and keep those things in reserve and
magnus has actually
retreated his knight you know maybe he's
going to maneuver it to a better square
yeah i i think that's his plan magnus
carson now he's brought his knight back
stepped it back but that's only because
he wants to step forward on the next
move so magnus carson
if we bring up the board he wants to
plant this knight into the center
potentially this knight will be very
very strong
ivanka calls it an octa knight in
control eight important squares
from the center of the board so also
this square would be anchored by white
pawn
in the middle i think this would be uh
his ideal scenario
maybe black can prevent that by trading
off a bishop for a knight
but in this type of scenario it's never
clear whose is better the knight
or the bishop i like the bishop because
there are pawns on both sides of the
board and bishops are long-range pieces
knights take longer to control both
sides but this would lead to some
imbalances and knights are very tricky
they can jump around they can attack
things
especially in these speed games yeah i
agree with you i mean i abs i
prefer the uh the rook and the bishop
together because they're just like the
perfect combo
the rook of the night maybe not so good
and also i love the fact that
the bishop can work on two different
flanks you can
work on the left side and the right side
such a long range piece love it
and uh definitely that's a decision that
hikaru has to think
really hard about whether to take you
know to take that night or not
i mean i i would be hesitant because
you're like you just said you know you
kind of
you kind of change the advantage of one
position into another type of thing
yeah it's something new to worry about
right and actually we see hikaru leaning
forward and
really studying this position he's now
five minutes below on the clock
and he's got a difficult uh choice to
make
that's one of magnus carlsen's strengths
i've realized i've played against him
actually during this lockdown in recent
months i've played against him so much
online
on blitz chess and he always gives you
options you always have
four or five different moves to consider
and often they're actually
roughly the same in terms of evaluation
but
you burn so much time on the clock just
wondering which one do you go for and
that's a very uh very good psychological
ploy by magnus that last move
hikaru meanwhile he's not feeling
confident um he's not
yet captured that night he might leave
that knight on the board okay he just
retreats his bishop instead
um i think a solid move but it did cost
him a lot of time
it did cost him a lot of time you know
and with these guys so good you know i
have to say that
i agree but i agree with you that it's
such a difficult decision to make you
know i would have hesitated for a long
time
and perhaps not done it as well and uh
retreating the bishop does look very
passive maybe i would have waited with
that
but uh these guys are geniuses and we
have a wonderful tweet from
rohm hosseini who says a few years ago i
thought watching chess post midnight was
boring
then i started watching hikaru and
magnus calculating moves and their
genius in action
i learn new things every game in chess
champs competitions
yeah i wonder how old rohan is hopefully
he's not staying up past his bedtime
to watch these games but he is right
though these players they calculate
moves so quickly
the reason black retreated his bishop
there is to clear that same square
for the black knight a very
sophisticated a very deep move by
nakamura both players we know they are
retreating but there's always a reason
for that retreat in general in chess you
want to push forward
but sometimes if you do take a step back
there has to be
a reason for that and a plan behind it
all right we see the tweets coming in
and we do have that
we do have that twitter quiz or the
question of the day ivanka yeah because
we've gotten to know so many animals
during this chess tour
so we decided yeah why not what is the
best
chess inspired name for a pet and
of course tweet us your answers on a
chess champs
and also if you want to send pictures
please use instagram and you can again
use the hashtag
chesschamps i actually did see someone
post a picture on
twitter of his dog and it seems this
dog's name is stalemate
that's a good that's a good chess
inspired pet name
does that i've never thought of that one
no i once saw a cartoon where it was
talking about bread
and then it said oh that bread looks
like it's going stale
chess humor chess humor yeah that's
right that's like that joke
you haven't heard that joke about um
this oh i don't know whether i should
tell a joke live on it
don't mess up the punchline well a man
gets a well a man puts a pocket
goes into his department store puts a
pocket chest sir
in his pocket and the security guard
taps him on the shoulder i guess
how are you going to pay for that and
the guy goes by check
mate
exactly but actually i mean i've never
had a pet so if any of these names are
especially good
i'll consider naming my first pet after
the winner's answer there
would you have tough question dogman or
catman uh i love them both but i'm
slightly allergic to cats
has to be the dog it has to be the dog
all right i think we actually we do have
a suggestion here on the screen actually
um
oh meow
meow nes
suggestion from derek h6
oh fantastic that makes it even better
meows i love it
carlson yeah thank you very much from oh
dennis
derek should i say derek yeah and
meanwhile magnus carson he spent a long
time in that last move he spent three or
four minutes
and he did relocate the white knight and
likewise
hikaru nakamura improving the black
knight that black knight now is actually
hitting a central pawn
that pawn was undefended therefore
magnus carson has advanced that pawn
uh magnus he's decided this is the
moment he's trying to push forward
those white pawns much further advanced
than their counterparts
white is trying to create a past pawn um
which will potentially be difficult to
stop
um hikara nakamura big big decision
right now does he trade pawns in the
centre of the board
or does he push forward and allow magnus
carson to create that very strong
protected passport all right interesting
and then
we actually do see two games have
finished penta lahari krishna and wesley
sawyer vancouver can you believe it it
ended in a draw oh but this is bad news
for friend tyler harry krishna
you know he he's in a must-win situation
for the last round and even then it's
not certain
and then we also see david anton and
yana pomniacci
play the draw so it's all over for david
anton as well unfortunately yeah
unfortunate
it's a bit of a [ __ ] you know it's a bit
of a shame that you know he
perhaps wanted a little bit more because
you know he started so well in the
skilling open i think he raced the lead
and he just wasn't his tournament just
wasn't his tournament now
this game you've been saying for a long
time it did look like a draw
what's your bet right now this one is so
hard to call
um chances are still balanced with best
play it should still be a draw
um simply because so many pieces have
been traded so many pawns
but i still have a feeling there are
there are some
kind of twists and turns ahead and there
we see a very
controversial decision by hikaru
nakamura it's
one that has long-term consequences if
we bring up the analysis board we can
see what's just happened
um actually the key moment was probably
just two moves ago magnus carson pushing
this pawn forward
one square he is attacking a pawn
nakamura had to decide
does he trade or does he step forward if
he'd captured
white would create a passport this pawn
is ready to race through to the end of
the board it has no rival
also white would be attacking a bishop
with his rook this rook would be given
an open line
therefore he decided to block it up but
after magnus carson's move
retreating the knight attacking this
undefended pawn suddenly
look at this pawn white's central pawn
is such a strength we call this a
protected past spawn
it has no rival later it will try and
run towards the end of the board
but more importantly it is protected it
does have a mate it does have a fellow
protecting it
it's going to be an eternal strength
something that nakamura has to worry
about for the rest of the game
absolutely he does have to worry about
it that's such a controversial decision
i would have really hesitated to allow
porn like that because that is the best
type of pawn there is on the board
i mean the only good thing i can see for
hikaru
is that he does have the you know just
like we have the best type of porn
there's also the best type of blockaders
queens are awful
don't worry you don't want to blockade
anything with the queen but the knights
are the best ones because
when the knight is standing in front of
an enemy pawn it is still
working away but here we have a very
mysterious rook move
by um hikaru nakamura just passively
defending the pawn
and uh yeah i didn't expect that one
yeah i think
hikaru nakamura we talked about that
protected past porn
he needs to blockade it and the best
blockading pieces of ankle mentions they
are
knights knights they can blockade things
while still controlling eight squares
that is the fantastic thing about
knights um the black knight will sit in
front of that uh central white pawn
but the problem is long term if all of
the pieces come off the board now
if the knights the bishops and the rooks
are all traded white will win
magnus carlsen will win because
protected past pawns are
vital in king and pawn end games so long
term that's what magnus carlsen will be
aiming for he'll be aiming to trade off
all of the pieces now
and rely on that protective past pawn to
win him the game
yeah yeah absolutely that's such a great
pawn
and uh now we can let's see if that
that's
that plan actually gets put into
operation i would like to see these
because often they happen
not just immediately you won't see like
a big rush of pieces you'll see like
some small things happen like
wonking slowly advances some pieces get
slowly attacked
and then before you know it knights have
maneuvered themselves into the best spot
and
well as you say in the uk bob's your
uncle
suddenly there's a winning winning king
and pawn ending this is your uncle
yeah and that's the beauty i find of
playing
through the games of these top players
especially these decisive results
when we do have them is that sometimes
you'll play through an
80 move game and you stop at certain
points you stop at move 20 you think
okay what are the long term plans for
either side
and then you stop a few moves later you
think maybe move 40 you think okay what
are the long term plans for either side
somehow one of the players always seems
to get their plan in
it might take 20 moves 13 moves 40 moves
but
as long as you know what to aim for it
makes the journey getting there
so much easier and actually that's how
they study chess
in places like russia they study the end
game first because then it makes it
easier once they know
what they are aiming for what they want
to be left with um it makes it easier
the rest of the game
right exactly i mean i've seen
situations where you're just like okay
bishop bishop if i go for a bishop
ending that's it
it's one and before we know it they've
gone for a bishop ending and they've
paid into it
and the other opponent didn't actually
realize that that was what was needed
and they've kind of fallen into it like
hook line and sinker and
that's it game over yeah i found myself
when i was first learning the moves when
i was
making my journey um through the ranks i
struggled to know what i should be
aiming for which pieces to
exchange and that's why studying in
games i mean there are plenty of places
to study end games for example on
chessable
and we mentioned the chessable challenge
earlier there are great courses on there
as well end game courses magnus carlsen
explains his best end games
on that site yeah there's so much um so
many
good tools out there to learn in-game
and that will help not just in the end
uh it will help all parts of your yeah
there's one actually really great
in-game course that they have there
which is the hundred end games you need
to know which is based on a book
and they've even got magnus carlsen and
some other top grand masters doing it
and it was quite interesting with magnus
carlsen because he was pitted against
his dad
[Laughter]
he's not a very good player his dad had
read that book and his dad had taken the
test
and then magnus was like okay i've got
to beat my dad and we're allowed to know
who won or spoilers
no i i think we can guess
and uh magnus i mean i first played him
when we were both nine ten years old and
um he's been an endgame virtuoso as
ciavanko mentions he's been that for
the whole time and meanwhile if we
if we catch up with the game there have
been a few small developments
if we bring up the analysis board we can
see what black has done
so nicely i feel to try and combat this
protected past pawn he's just planted
his knight in front of it
this night we mentioned is a great
blockader only one piece can actually
remove this knight from blockading that
pawn
and that is the white knight therefore
magnus carson his next move he wants to
bring his knight to the center
exchange off this black knight just to
clear the path
for his remaining pawn that's magnus's
plan meanwhile black
hikaru nakamura he needs to maintain
this knight or he needs to start
creating some counter play maybe he'll
start playing on this right side of the
board
maybe he'll bring his king towards the
center i think this is a critical moment
for kara nakamura if he can find a good
way
to maintain his knight then he'll he's
got great chances in this game
if magnus can trade off that black
knight i think magnus will be in charge
when was the do you remember the result
in the very first game you played
against magnus in your life
yes i remember all of them partly
because i didn't win any of them
um yeah we played i think four draws at
the beginning and then
he's beaten me the most recent times um
we have however played lots of
online blitz and yeah i do lose a lot of
games there but i have one of you
so have you played all of the
participants and they uh
i've played all of them in over the
board chess
apart from rajabov actually rajabov
somehow never seems to be the same
tournaments as me all of the others i've
played on several occasions
well we can start to see uh david's plan
being put into action you see suddenly
why magnus has mobilized rook and you
can see that
magnus is ready to kind of swap off
knights if he wants to
yeah and i think it would be very
tempting for magnus carlsen right now to
trade those knights off immediately
there's maybe no rush he can trade them
off in the next few moves
what i would be looking at though we
mentioned earlier always look for checks
and captures in every position
so white can give a check with his
knight attacking the king attacking the
black knight black has to take it back
and after white recaptures maybe what
we'll see is black
use his king to blockade this past pawn
suddenly the king will act
as a blockader um yeah i'm not sure
whether magnus cast and he should rush
into this decision maybe he wants to
keep the tension another thing i'd be
considering
is whether to improve white's king bring
that one towards the center maybe to
open up the right side of the board
open up some lines with the pawn trades
because remember the long-term advantage
favors white he has this very strong
pawn in the middle of the board
so magnus carson he'll just try and keep
the tension and rely on that pawn to
make the difference later
yeah i just love that kind of like
slowly improving with the king first
and keeping the option open because yes
we want oh no he's gone for it
he's not a patient person well he is
really but okay so we now see a night
trade
and uh now okay now magnus has got his
plan in
and there is a big threat in the
position actually because uh
white can advance the pawn the big
central pawn
and unleash this bishop
that's right if white gets a chance to
push this pawn forward then
this bishop would suddenly attack a pawn
um white would win a pawn in that
situation the white pawn attacking a
rook forcing it to retreat
then the poor oh sorry then the pawn
next to it would drop off so
big big threat this pawn push i would
try and stop it with my king right now
maybe hikaru nakamura he might try he
might allow that pawn to push forward he
might try and improve this
black rook right now it needs to somehow
recentralize itself it's just blocked by
its own pawns
um a key moment for hikaru nakamura
actually he didn't go for that he pushed
a pawn forward on this left side
he's just trying to open things up now
himself trying to create some counter
play he wants to start pushing his own
pawns
and we might see a trade in a moment
white has two choices to capture here
or we mentioned this special move
earlier where i can actually take this
pawn
on passant because it has just moved two
squares it's the first time that pawn
has been pushed so white can actually
capture it
with his own pawn well that timing would
be perfect since we just
in the video had you later teach us the
ampersand
why is the name of it so french there's
quite a few french terms
yeah we have jadub as well which is kind
of i adjust
exactly the players before and over the
board game they say
which means they're allowed to touch the
pieces to adjust them
even during the games if this piece
isn't firmly on the center if it's kind
of in the middle of a square
you have to say shadow first because if
you touch the piece you actually have to
move it
so if you say shadow first you can just
adjust it well we don't have that
problem in online chess do we
only mouse slips in online chess only
mouse slips and uh
yeah well okay things have been really
heating up because magnus has taken a
very committal decision
he has pushed the central past pawn and
now there's going to be a big
elimination in the center and
you see some trades and wow that that
pawn is two squares away from
coining that's right white wants to make
a new queen look how far advanced that
white pawn is in the center
but at the moment it doesn't have much
backup it doesn't have much support
therefore nakamura he's relying on the
fact that that white point is more of a
weakness than a strength
i don't like that last move though um
with black's bishop i'm
very surprised i think hikara nakamura
maybe he's sensing the tension
with his clock ticking down um magnus
carson does have a couple of extra
minutes right now
suddenly white's rook is on an open line
rooks love these open lines white's rook
can suddenly
zoom up into the black's position um
also white's pawn it can advance
even further if it wants to um as black
i'm so surprised hikaru nakamura
removed the blockade of that white pawn
i would have kept my bishop right in
front of it
if i could yeah exactly i would have
also kept my
bishop in the way of the rook and now
the rook has moved to the perfect
perfect
line and hikaru is desperately attacking
that
all-important pawn there's two squares
away from
queening oh oh but look at the bar
i know it's it's i think white
definitely has the advantage here
it's still maybe not winning immediately
it's not the decisive advantage that
magnus is looking for and the bar does
recorrect itself
it has the computer it looked a bit
deeper and seen that white
isn't quite winning but we do see a
trade there
i'm surprised i would have kept that
pawn as white i would have kept the pawn
in the center
moved it up one square instead we see
that magnus he's captured black's pawn
on that left edge of the board he's
captured that pawn but he has lost that
uh very dominant central pawn that he
had a moment ago
uh magnus he's attacking porn now he's
attacking one of black sports with this
rook but black's rook has finally got
active
now there's one dangerous move here okay
so okay but the magnus spotted it
because there was the opportunity
to fall into a checkmate yeah and if we
bring up the board we can see
magnus carlson he avoided that trap
doesn't really mean that one it was a
mean one
and it's such a natural uh trap to fall
into black gave a check with his rook
hoping that magnus carlsen hoping that
white would just play a natural move
step forward with his king normally we
want to centralize our king in the end
game
white bringing his king forward
attacking the black rook but suddenly
there would be a devastating checkmate
on the board rook would come across
attacking the white king the rook is
also protected by its bishop
uh and the white king is actually
trapped the white king is checkmated in
the middle of the board
uh this would be a rare type of
checkmate instead magnus carson forced
to play a move he doesn't want to play
he tucks his king away
back in the corner far away from the
action
all right and we do see uh two more
games haven't ended we're back to all
the draws now um
maximum vagielagrava and tv timor rajabo
played the draw and so did daniel dubo
and lavon so it's all up to carl's
nakamura
and anish geary and alexander grishock
to fill up with
some decided games here some wins and
losses
yeah and that's bad news for maxine
vasily grav i think that pretty much
mathematically eliminates him now um we
thought he needed to win both of his
last two games
just to have a chance of qualifying his
fate is definitely out of his own hands
yep he can only get five points at the
maximum now and he is facing timor
jar no he's not he's facing alexander
grishock
in the last round so probably it's all
over for the frenchman
unfortunately such a great player it's
going to be sad to not see him play
quarter-finals
yeah just somehow not quite at his best
and hit the key moment the turning point
was that loss against aneshiri that we
saw earlier
that very dramatic game yeah definitely
you know it's very
he's such a marvelous tactical tricky
player i really do enjoy watching him
play so it would be very sad that he
doesn't reach the quarterfinals but
so be it one player that we definitely
going to keep an eye on is one player
that is still playing and that is
um aneesh giri he is currently in ninth
place i think so he's just outside the
quarterfinals he's gonna have to fight
in this game and in the last game
yeah he'll i mean that's why he's still
pressing for that win um he's gonna try
and
uh take any chance he gets and meanwhile
uh hikaru nakamura had a long long think
that now only two and a half minutes on
his clock
i think he might have just made a
decisive mistake i'm wow
shocked by that last move i don't really
understand it and i said the bar has
gone
up all the way up to the white side and
like isn't this just a pin
yeah magnus carlsen we see the stock
fish stockfish the computer
suggestions are just below the players
right now there's only
uh one move which is winning for white
it will give them a plus
five advantage every other move will
just be a draw
all right so let's just keep an eye on
that white rook now magnus carlsen if he
wants to win this game this is the move
he
needs to find oh that's exciting and it
seems to me like we've wrapped in with
coincidence because this was
what you were studying in the chesapore
course how was it
wait i can't see it what is it
and you win
yes okay i see it now yeah so white's
rook we're looking for that white rook
to just step across
one square um if it just moves across
suddenly there's
a really devastating attack down this
line
and we call it a pin because a lesser
piece this black bishop is attacked if
it moves
then it gives way to an attack on a
larger piece
magnus looking away oh yeah just look at
his reaction
messed up and yeah you can see it
suddenly black is forced to
either lose a bishop or trade off into a
losing king and poor man game okay
he has defended his bishop hikaru
nakamura he stepped across with his king
defending this bishop attacking the
white rook
white's rook just stepped up one square
but the problem is for black his bishop
is paralyzed this is going to remain
this pin this very awkward pin meanwhile
if black can't make moves
white's pawn is just going to race to
his promotion square black is just
completely paralyzed
um okay he has pushed a pawn forward
there's a bit of a race here
white's pawn is running black's pawn is
running but if magnus carson is careful
he should win this game now okay this is
now super exciting if magnus carlson
manages to beat kore and nakamura in
this game then magnus carlsen will take
the lead
uh in the preliminaries before that last
round and we know it's
always it's always that advantage to get
on top in the press and the pawn race is
happening
magnus has advanced his pawn and so now
we're going to see it
and now i think we're going to see a
bishop trade
yeah and the problem is for white
there's a key detail okay
white's rook has captured the bishop um
and hikara nakamura he just resigns
he's just given up wow so sudden we'll
go back to explain that moment
uh shortly um but shocking stuff from
hikara nakamura he
was fighting well he was defended
perfectly he was still in the game and
it all just fell apart so quickly so
dramatically
wow okay um well it did seem for a long
time that magnus did have an advantage
for a long time here but
it was eventually a blunder by hikaru
that did this
and it's no coincidence that hikaru
blundered it's because he was on the
back foot he was on the defensive for
the whole game and
psychologically that is hard um
maybe we can bring up the board just to
show why hikaru resigned at the end
because it's not obvious at first sight
we did see in this position
both pawns both pawns running down the
board white's pawn is running black's
pawn is running but the key factor
after magnus carson played rook captures
bishop
is that in this position if black
recaptures back
we see a lot of trades and in this
position both sides are about to make
queens
but white wins the race white makes the
queen first and
he promotes with check so black doesn't
have enough time to make a queen of his
own
that's the difference between one tempo
just giving that check
um that must have been what hikaru
nakamura had miscalculated he missed
that his king was attacked and
yeah i agree i agree i think he just
calculated that all the trades would
happen he would catch the pawn
yeah all good except it wasn't except he
forgot that his pieces were in a
complete bind
and that magnus could just freely
advance that pawn and yeah that's it
game over and i agree with you david
this is kind of like magnus's strategy
you put the pressure on you put the
pressure
until it cracks wow and that means
magnus carlsen
is now in top of the table he's gotten
two wins now he won against daniel
dubois yesterday
and this is probably his favorite win
beating hikaru nakamura
definitely one of his biggest rivals
probably for the air things masters
crown and
the style in which he did it i mean he i
think he lulled nakamura into this false
sense of security
it looked like he was heading down this
drawish opening and suddenly
he started applying the pressure and it
all paid out in the end all right we are
going to finish up this round
10 in the air things monster is only one
round left after this round
anish geary is one of the players
currently outside
the qualified top eight for the
quarterfinals uh he is playing
alexander grisha here he was playing
okay well we managed just to see
alexander grishard leave
the computer um i'm guessing this is a
draw um yes
it looks like the player's actually in
this final position they just agree to a
draw because there's no way
that either side can make progress it
does look like white
is in control but black was too solid
all right wow that was fast
okay uh we have now finished 10 of 11
rounds in the air things monsters
preliminaries only one
one round remain and to join us now
building up to that last very important
round we have
grandmaster simon williams joining us hi
simon
hi how are you all doing good we're good
we're excited because we haven't had
that many drawers today still quite a
few but not that many how are you
feeling about that
yeah it seems to be a really exciting
day um often this is the case where
they're getting to that qualification
sort of last countdown kind of situation
and they the pressure's building
some of them have got to win some don't
want to draw but it's so
close at the top now i think going into
this last round
there's many people who can go through
many people can get knocked out
just depending how they play so i'm very
excited at the moment
who are you most excited to follow now
in the last round with
four players leaving us after that round
i'm but i'm actually quite excited to
see anish in east geary i
i want to see him qualify because he's
been one of the most aggressive players
in the tournament so um i'm looking
forward to see how it here get on
uh it looks like carson is back on form
beating hikaru there so he's finally
found his form
and one of my favorite tournament
players throughout the storm has also
been daniel
duboff so uh i've got my fingers crossed
for him as well
so simon yesterday you were critical and
i think
rightly so of wesley so for taking the
draws today you must be
very happy to see many more decisive
games already in the first round
just as many decisive games as we saw
the whole of yes ah that's true
yeah it's been great i mean they've come
out swinging at each other which i
really like you know they could have sat
there and tried to draw the way through
which i think has been
wesley's approach i mean i was quite
critical of him yesterday but it's
working out for him
um i mean we all want to see a bit of a
slugfest and that is happening
actually i noticed with the russian
players they seem to be coming out and
really fighting which is quite
interesting um but
yeah i mean anything like you say could
happen in this last round coming up
do you think anyone be will be able to
make a big comeback i'm thinking of
anish giri
and pantala harry krishna do you think
they can do it
i've got my fingers crossed for a niche
because i mean he's got this kind of uh
rivalry with magnus carlsen which we've
mentioned before
in the skilling open and he he's quite
an amusing chap
you know he's he's a he's a funny chat
very witty so i'm kind of like secretly
rooting for a niche to get through and
and to face magnus and
maybe one day beat magnus because then i
want to see the twitter warfare and that
will ensure after that which
will be worth it just for that so yeah
simon just i just have to ask you
we have a little bit of a chess quiz
going on what is the best
chess inspired name for a pet and i'll
put you on the spot but you actually
have a pet yeah
well harry of course
harry the cat or harry harry the dog um
something like that i mean you could
call it after one of your favorite chess
players like
maybe magnus magnus the cat i don't know
possibly
so uh what names do you come up with my
suggestion was uh cat sparrow
oh that's quite good i like the fish
i like that one yes and bobby fish oh
simon you have a very famous cat
yourself right oh i do
i do charlie the chess cat yeah charlie
the chess cat is my cat who often
comes and sits at the table watches me
play chess and uh
yeah he's got he's got his own facebook
page which is a little bit weird but
anyway
fantastic okay well simon uh we like to
ask you every day about your favorite
move of the day and you have chosen
a move in a game that was actually
decided with a winner
that's right yeah it's a really
interesting game in round one between
the two russian players nepo
and duboff and uh we see that got this
position nepo with the white pieces and
duboff was literally going crazy in this
game it's the kind of game
where he sees white's king and he throws
everything
at white's king the kitchen sink the
pieces
and we can see here his rook is attacked
in the middle of the board
and i was watching at this moment in
time and the normal player would kind of
move that rook away
you know somewhere safe where it can't
be captured but
he's not really a normal player duboff
instead of retreating this guy just
loves coming forwards and he plays the
amazing idea
rook to e3 now the reason this is such
an amazing idea
is the rook is worth five points and the
bishop is worth three points
he's already material down points down
and he just throws more wood on the fire
he's basically saying have all my pieces
i'm going to check mate you so
really really brave play and the game
continued with here
with him fighting on him in a very
interesting situation
the bishop comes in with check and now
his other bishop
comes in to that square and uh it was it
was an exciting game it failed
they do say fortune should favor the
brave but
in this case it did fail him and white
defended brilliantly and won but
i still like the spirit that was shown
there um
in this game and simon another
move that uh excited you in this game
i've heard
yeah there was i mean just in that
position you got to there's this crazy
move here where
where black has all these pieces kind of
doing aggressive things
and that queen of his the queen being
the most powerful piece you'd imagine it
to jump into the action because
it wants to you know wants to have a
piece piece of the fight it just slides
its way back into the corner
and this is an unbelievable idea it's
kind of
resembles an alpha zero move alpha zero
being
the strongest ever computer program
alpha zero played moves like this
and the idea of this is to support harry
the h pawn
good on you queen and harry the h pawn
wants to come up
to h5 and trap white's queen so
it was it was an amazingly imaginative
idea but
in the end maybe a little bit too
imaginative
uh because it failed so yeah yeah
all right simon uh thank you so much for
joining us your final predictions for
anish giri facing hikaru nakamura in the
last round do you think
anish will qualify for the quarter
finals
i i'm gonna say yes i've gotta i've
gotta stick my words come on anish you
gotta do
you gotta do the business here and uh i
hope he does the business and manages to
win that one
perfect all right again it's getting
close thank you so much for joining us
simon
yes see you again
[Music]
this is the moment it has come up to the
final round in the preliminaries of the
air things masters
12 players will become eight after this
round four will be knocked out and
nothing has yet been decided
it's going to get so interesting
[Music]
and here we have the results from the
10th
round with only one round to go magnus
carlsen did manage to get that win
against hikaru nakamura
and he is now in seoul lead and then we
had
a bunch of draws in the other games and
that means david
it's it's all up to that last round on
the preliminaries
yeah as you mentioned nothing's been
decided nobody
is safe quite yet um i can't predict
anything i mean
these players they'll have their
calculators out they'll be trying to
work out the consequences of their next
result
and here we have it the standings with
magnus carlsen on top
and then five six is it seven players on
five
no five players on five and a half and
two players on five points and then we
do have those four
bottom players that needs to fight on
each geary
is currently outside the top eight and
uh
we have to remember also ivanka it's not
only about qualifying
number one will face number eight number
two will face number seven in the
quarterfinals exactly
those positions are quite important
because they determine the pairings and
they also determine
whether you get your choice of color and
also whether you're going to get white
or black in the all-important armageddon
game
if it comes to that far so yeah
absolutely
impressive so what i'm wanting that the
players are getting ready i just have to
tell you this
well we have some one player in
particular who's been tweeting
everyone again and you guess who no not
during the games actually
after the games i'm guessing an ishkiri
yes and
of course he is playing hikaru nakamura
and hikaru has a course
qualified and he suggests the hikaru
maybe play the bong cloud which is
actually just to move the king
very early on in the opening
and it's kind of a reference to nakamura
doing that in the us chess championships
against another opponent when he the
result didn't matter
so yeah all right why don't you eat
there by anish giri before the last
round of the preliminaries ladies and
gentlemen
it is about to start and these are the
games for the final round alexander
grishok
will face maxim vacher lagrave who is
currently out
of top eight and then we have the game
between
um miana pognati he's going to play
magnus carlsen who isn't so lead
next game we will have is levon aronian
playing david anton who unfortunately
is out of the tournament and then we
have wesley so who's playing so many
draws but he's now going to play donald
dubo
who usually pushes for the win so
interesting game there and then we have
timor rajabo he is going to play pantala
hari krishna and then the game that we
will follow hikaru nakamura coming from
a loss
against magnus carlson playing
anishigiri
who simply needs to win this game david
yeah anish
i mean he knows what he needs right now
his fate is still in his own hands if he
wins
there's still a decent chance he'll
qualify but he is facing
a pretty scary opponent hikaru nakamura
and
hikara nakamura bent on revenge for that
last game and we did see
most of the players being ready for this
final round in the preliminaries of the
air things masters
hoping to qualify for those
quarter-finals but two players are
missing
and it is hikar nakamura and the niche
gear what are they i mean we don't know
if um
anish gear is missing because he's been
invisible all day that's right he's
forgotten to take his invisibility cloak
off
meanwhile hikaru nakamura in his lucky
shirt wasn't so lucky in that last game
and it looks like he is ready to kick
off all right well
can mention it enough it's all about
winning this game for anish
geary if he wants to qualify for the
quarter finals
probably it's all about winning yes yes
he knows that a draw won't be enough by
the way and you have the calculator
ready david
i do have the sparkly homemade
calculator
ready to work out all the tie break
rules um who makes the cut and who
doesn't exactly because it's not
just about whether anish wins he also
needs other people to lose or
or maybe even to draw so yeah
yeah and that's right the players have
started now hikaru nakamura opening with
his kings pawn
um this is something he's been doing for
many many years anishkiri
playing the sicilian defense is only a
recent
addition to his opening repertoire but
he plays it when he needs to win in
must-win situations
that shows that as black anishigiri he's
not allowing the game to fizzle out we
will see
uh excitement in this game we'll see a
full-blooded fight a very rich
dynamic position meanwhile black's last
move bringing out that knight attacking
white's pawn in the center of the board
which
isn't currently defended um anishikuri
asking questions
to kara nakamura at this early stage all
right can we
tell um from this that um i mean anyone
is pushing for a win here
anish he's not allowing hikara to shut
down this game
a draw is enough for hikaru nakamura to
go through for any giri it's not so
um yeah anishigiri definitely definitely
trying to play for a complicated battle
and black now taking space in the center
black's pawns are further advanced than
their rivals
hikara nakamura just defending his
central pawn there bringing knight
towards the center
this game is going to revolve around the
middle of the board for the next few
moves
but it is kind of well known that this
opening later in the game
does become very very imbalanced quite
often attacks on the right black attacks
on the left
yeah it is going to be super imbalanced
i agree with you david
we're going to see a series of moves
that actually been seen before many many
times and was in fact a famous
um as a favorite of bobby fischer
himself that's right you really like
this opening so let's
see how it progresses yeah bobby fischer
won many
many games with this type of setup as
white uh
while he was in his prime and there we
see white has committed his king
to the uh to that right side of the
board i think black will
follow suit black will copy that
anishigiri he's taking a pause though
because he knows that white has
committed his king okay he does
as well uh follow that i thought maybe
he would take inspiration from that
winning he had against maxim vashly grab
earlier and try and castle his king on
the opposite side of the board
when i mean chaos would break out um
meanwhile waitress centralizing his rook
bringing his rook towards the center
this has all been seen before this is
very classical stuff
karu yawning maybe he's just it's early
it is early morning yeah you do have to
remember that so only what is it like
eight o'clock in the morning i think for
hikaru and he's been playing for a few
hours already
and uh luckily we're now seeing in here
i i
hardly noticed that he just showed up
here now we've missed him yeah
we missed him and yeah and he's going to
be playing a very mysterious move
that on that last turn just pushing a
pawn near the black king
um i'm not sure i've seen that one
before hikaru
looks like he hasn't either he's
frowning slightly um hikaru he normally
looks up
to the left when he's trying to remember
something but if he looks down and he
frowns slightly it means
it's new to him he hasn't seen this one
before and i
agree it's new to me too i was expecting
um
a much more aggressive approach on the
left-hand side of the board for him to
just
for a niche just to throw those pawns
forward and we would have seen a race
but uh no we have something unusual
yeah a bit of a waiting move there from
anishiri uh maybe he just wants to
build the tension until a critical
moment and then
make his move and then start uh start
the complications
at the moment that's just asking hikaru
what is your plan so hikaru he'll take a
pause here he's already spent a minute
um okay there we see a bit of a waiting
move as well from hikaru and nakamura
just advancing a point
only one square gaining a little bit
more control over the center
both sides i think a bit indecisive
right now but also
just waiting for their opponents to
reveal their hands
all right well oh and oh here he comes
yeah he's going for it in this game he's
yeah he's pulling forward
on that left side um yeah i think he's
just gonna push
everything on that left side i wouldn't
be expect i wouldn't be surprised
to see all of anikeri's pawns there on
the left
fly forward into white side of the board
um okay hikara nakamura meanwhile has
captured in the middle and
he's got his bluffing face on he's
frowning slightly oh is this the
bluffing face i was
thinking about it because it looks so
overly
suspicious yeah i think he's hoping
maybe that anishigiri is watching the
webcams
he's maybe hoping to get inside danish
giri's head um he knows anish he's only
focused on one thing right now anish is
focused on that win
only one result so maybe hikaru he's
just adding a bit of mind games
yeah well a lot of the players have
actually told us that especially when
playing hikaru nakamura they like to
just turn their opponent's webcam off
it's no point in
watching him because he always tries to
to fake it yes
that's right and he's extremely good at
those psychological
battles meanwhile a porn has been traded
the first piece has left the board at
least pawns have been traded in the
center
black's knight recapturing a pawn there
i love that black knight in the middle
of the board
uh hikaru he'll be deciding how to get
rid of that black knight now
does he jump forward with his own knight
white also could occupy the center with
one of his own
uh with one of his own steeds but yeah
black meanwhile i think
and he'll be happy with the outcome of
the opening yeah i think so and
you know it's the kind of position that
perhaps he would be quite quite liking
because i personally
would would also like it if my opponent
just eliminated in the center and didn't
go full throttle with me
in the attack okay so we have some moves
and in fact all this has been
played before wow just one game mind you
but uh so far it's so good they're
following a game from 2019.
okay would we know those players ivanka
no okay
so maybe these players they're on new
territory maybe they don't realize this
has actually been seen before we are
move 12.
normally the players are very well
prepared they study their ropings in
great depth
but around this stage once both kings
have castled
um that tends to be when players start
to
be on their own starting trying to
figure out the plans and it i think
definitely at least from an issue side
we can see him zoned in here thinking
he's just deciding
where to put that black knight if we
bring up the analysis board we can see
hikara's last move it's a very committal
one
white's last move is to push this pawn
forward one square remember that pawn
already moved
forward one square just two moves ago so
spending another turn
pushing that pawn forward the idea is to
get rid of an opponent's centralized
knight if your opponent has a knight in
the center
it's always a good idea to kick it away
and anish has a bit of an issue here
he has to decide does he retreat the
knight this way does he retreat it back
towards his own king
lots of choice either way if he retreats
his knight there might be issues along
this diagonal
white bishop a bit of x-ray vision here
is looking at this black
undefended rook in the corner so for
example he could jump forward with his
knight
and potentially attack this rook if the
if
black's knight moves we might see a
capture and lots of stuff is happening
here
the game goes on it's still nothing
decided it's very complicated
but that is uh hikaru's plan to make use
of his bishop against that on defender
blackrook
yeah absolutely you know that is the
whole point of why it's play you know
just to
use that power of that bishop that is on
the most perfect diagonal
you know most most pieces actually have
perfect squares don't they so this
bishop
for instance wants to be on the longest
diagonal possible allocate and we have
a new move actually this is the new move
that he has retweeted the square the
night
to a square on the left side of the
board
and uh yeah things are certainly heating
up
yeah and i think that's a sensible move
by anish giri so actually the knight
retreat it did defend that rook in the
corner the black rook in the corner but
the night now that black knight is
further away from his own king we said
it before knight to king's best friend
black has no pieces around his own king
right now so later
not right now but a bit later if white
can stir up an attack against the black
king
there won't be too many defenders
meanwhile anishgiri trying to challenge
that long diagonal we mentioned the
white bishop being very strong
potentially
i left the bar i have to say look at the
bar really does not like
black's position it's really loving
white and
and the material is equal we have to
remind everyone because uh
yeah when you're a pawn up or two pawns
up okay that will usually be reflected
in the bar and but here the material is
equal and
yeah it's it's a saying quite
significantly an advantage
for hikaru yeah i think the last few
moves have gone in hikaru nakamura's
favor
i'm looking out for two moves here from
hikaru i think two moves maybe give the
advantage and both of them
involve improving this bishop um this
bishop can jump out it can
okay he has brought it out he's
attacking this pawn twice now with the
knight and the bishop a bit of teamwork
ganging up on this weak pawn
and look at this poor black knight it's
had to it's had to
place itself on the edge of the board
doing a defensive job it can't jump
anywhere it's just
stuck defending one of its own pawns and
hikaru he says okay
i'm not going to waste a moment i'm
going to punish you for putting a knight
on the edge of board he's exploding open
the center with this last move
pushing the pawn forward i think anish
giri he's going to regret having to put
his knight on the edge of the board
though
and meanwhile one game has already
finished and it is uh janupogniacci
versus magnus carlsen
it ended in a draw magnus carlson
currently in seoul lead with
six and a half points it's definitely
not certain he will be the winner of the
preliminaries
but it is a good chance he will be the
winner of the preliminaries and uh
i'm going to look down the list for jana
pomnyacci currently then in
second with six points um so he's also
qualified
for the quarter finals yeah i think for
both of those players it just makes
sense to play it safe they don't want to
risk their qualification
um just by pressing too hard in the last
game imagine going all out for the win
and suddenly realize you've been knocked
out
a sensible result from both players
there yes well i'm actually not
a hundred percent sure no certain niana
pogba she has qualified i mean obviously
a lot of players can still
go past him i mean this is going to be a
hectic hour for us now trying to figure
out
who can actually qualify and who can't
well that's okay kyle because we have
we calculated so many permutations
we're working out we're working out yeah
i've got the answer
okay so what is the answer is uh
definitely qualified
i think he's odds-on yes yeah i think
it's
almost certain i think he's guaranteed
guaranteed into the
into the quarter-finals and uh yes i
think it's the
inigiri hari krishna who need to
win and those people hovering around the
eighth mark who need to
really make sure that they don't lose
yeah i think in seventh and eighth place
um daniel dubov and alexander grisham
those are the guys in danger of
like they've got a trap door beneath
them they just can't fall through that
trap door they have to hope that the
players beneath them
do not win um they might be keeping an
eye as well danny lubov and alexander
on this game if hikaru is able to win
they'll breathe a sigh of relief and
they'll relax a bit but
um if any does win then he might be able
to
jump up and replace them and meanwhile
we do have seen a trade of pawns in the
center and black just stepping
across one square with his queen to just
defend the knight in front of it
very tense hikaru didn't look too happy
i think maybe he missed that last move
but white is still in control yeah i
mean what i really am a bit afraid for
anish because obviously we do like the
comeback story
well it's the fact that okay hikaru has
a better position but also
the center is very fluid and i can just
see a lot of trades happening
and that uh it will be very very very
difficult for anish to actually pull off
a victory
because the draw is not sufficient yeah
i agree completely and
i'm still worried about that black
knight that black knight on the edge of
the board there
it's struggling to get back in the game
it's already moved
four times just to get to the edge of
the board um
yeah i think that knight is on a bad
circuit he's wasted too many moves
already with that knight it's going to
struggle
to get back in the game and one bad
piece often makes the position bad
yeah absolutely and all the pressure is
rising i mean would you be thinking if
you were a niche geary right now
i'd be thinking try and survive as long
as possible
get my pieces out get that knife back
towards the center get that black rook
in the
in the top left corner is trapped right
now get that into the game
and then start to worry about trying to
win trying to set some traps and create
chances
he can't be worried about the result
right now especially because he's
struggling a bit the last few moves have
gone in white's favor
as black he just needs to be saying uh
saying to himself stay in the game as
long as possible the tension will build
later on
he will get a chance at some point he
just needs to make sure he's fully ready
to take it
yeah and if say for instance hikaru just
launches
beast mode and just kind of goes well
you know your queen is on the left side
of the board
i'm going to look at the right side
would you be like ah
a panic or do you think what do you
would you think
or do you think that perhaps okay well
this means that hikaru wants to take
risks
and i don't have to worry about the
position being traded off into
a completely drawn yeah sometimes
actually the best way to win
these games especially against the very
top players in the world is for them to
come
at you so that you can counter attack a
bit later on it means that they
are kind of they're not thinking about
the draw they are going for the decisive
result and
it just makes things easier it makes it
easier to get a kind of imbalanced game
to
uh to really complicate things to make
things messy and if things get messy
that's when anish giri will get his
chance he's going to be hoping that
nakamura doesn't try to just trade
everything off and settle for the draw
hmm all right and anish gary well we
know he
needs to win in this game to have a hope
of qualifying and then
i guess probably he's going to be
following daniel dubo and alexander
grishock's games
if he wants to qualify he he would hope
for a loss for alexander grish again for
daniel dubo in this last round
but we're paying attention to all of the
the games here all of the round all of
the
the games to see who's going to qualify
for quarter-finals
now uh hikarna kumara doesn't have to be
worried
he will qualify yeah and uh
you might not have to be worried about
his qualification but he does look
slightly worried he spent
over three minutes now on this move um
he's still frowning a bit
i i'm not sure he's um trying to work
out
a forced win right now but he will know
that his position is very good as white
so he will be looking for something
quite direct to punish anishikari for
putting that knight on the edge of the
board
that being said hikaru nakamura maybe
his confidence was affected by that last
loss
against magnus carson maybe that's why
he's been spending a bit more time here
than he normally would
normally would have done going under 10
minutes now hikaru nakamura
and i have to say nishigiri he's i've
seen him close his eyes quite a few
times during this game
trying to get like into zen mode maybe
yeah definitely he needs to keep his
emotions
calm because you know he has to focus on
what needs to be done and that is first
of all as david says
stage one survive this stage two get an
advantage
stage three win easier said than done
yeah there's three very big big asks
from him
but uh yeah we can see his co2 levels as
well maybe
yes i'm actually following it online
because obviously if you go to
airthings.com
chess then you can follow live all the
air quality for the players with the
device and it's yellow now the co2
levels
it's below thousand so air quality is
getting better furnish geary
okay and today has been his best day so
far um he's been playing well he got
that win against maxine vacheroligrave
yeah i think yeah there we see it yep
that's by far the best air quality he's
had
um and yeah that's no coincidence that
he uh
has been playing well meanwhile though
he does need to come up with a good move
here hikaru nakamura
spent a long time spent about four
minutes on the clock and just slowly
improved the white queen
um and hikaru is slightly shaking his
head there as well
i think it's time for um time for
anishigiri to either bring a rook into
the game
one of the black rooks i mean neither of
them are doing anything right now one of
them needs to be improved at least
or maybe anishikari he can start trading
some pieces and there we see okay he has
swaps and knights off in the middle of
the board a set of knights disappear
those bishops now those light square
bishops along the
i mean the very long diagonal there they
will also disappear from the board
sooner rather than later i would expect
anishigiri to capture that bishop right
now
there we go white recaptures
and anishikari he's actually got a very
healthy position
apart from that black knight on the co
in the corner um
i think it's time to figure out what to
do with that knight
or okay first he improves the rook
sensible played by anishigiri his
position
is slightly better it looks at least
slightly better than it was
just a few moves ago that being said
hikara nakamura
he'll still be happy his pieces are
slightly better especially his knight
the white knight is much better than
that black knight
is this looking very bad for an h geary
now uh considering he needs a win
in this game um i wouldn't it's
definitely not losing
um it's tricky it's just difficult yeah
i think it's going to be difficult to
create winning chances we did see a
couple of trades there and the more
pieces leave the board we've seen it
before
more pieces leave the board um the
closer we'll get to it yeah
we have a very very interesting move on
the board because hikaru
has just followed actually the computer
suggestion
and just moved the queen and sacrificed
a porn
wow and super exciting stuff and i think
it's
every you call it david is all gay oh
and anish has
quickly taken and look at the bar he
hates it is that a blunder
yeah yes i think it's a mistake but it's
it's kind of fueled by the tournament
situation and
normally he would not have played this
move so quickly and he should just
gobbling up a pawn here
taking this pawn which was undefended
but um
he's forced to take risks in this
tournament situation if he didn't
capture that pawn the best he could hope
for is a draw
now at least he has a pawn up he has
something to cling on to
he has something to hold on to if he
survives
which is far from a given then he'll
have an extra pawn the problem is
white's rook will swing across attacking
the black queen
black's queen only has one safe square
now he has to offer this trade
but when the queens disappear from the
board look at this
this black knight is trapped now at the
side of the board
the black knight has to i mean maybe it
can retreat to its start square but look
look at what might happen this black
knight
trapped this black rook trapped this
would be a dream porn sacrifice and
we're going down this line this is the
current position we're about to see the
queen's being traded
yeah exactly you know i have to say
about this one thing about the coverage
of both this event and the skilling open
is that the nights are really bad on the
edge of the board
and uh yeah you can see that that night
that anish has
it's just trapped it cut it can't make a
move i mean
it needs every single piece to defend it
though i think anish can only play um
he can only retreat the rook that rook
just kind of
yeah the black one like the light cannot
just uh
move yeah the black knight it can go
back to its start square but as we saw
there that would be very sad
white will be able to kind of box in
that black rook on the top left hand
corner
um therefore andi he might have to step
back with his rook in the middle
to defend the black knight actually he's
about to make a move i think
um but either way that pawn that he
grabbed
i actually admire his courage there to
take that pawn to be
greedy he needed to take that risk in
the tournament situation but it will
backfire hikara nakamura has worked this
all out in advance
he saw this hikaru nakamura five moves
beforehand i think
four or five moves beforehand he's
worked out that this position is good
for white
purely because of that black knight that
black knight is so bad oh
so horrible okay now okay
now all hikaru needs to do is deliver a
check and
now the two rooks will double up and
just look at that poor creature on the
corner
all right well as we are seeing some
drama on the board we are actually now
joined by magnus carlsen
who finished the preliminary he is
currently uh the leader the winner of
the preliminaries and
magnus and congratulations on qualifying
for quarter finals
uh thank you so much uh didn't know that
i've won the uh
the preliminaries though uh i don't i
know nobody can get
yeah so at any rate i'll get the one of
the first
uh first few seats um
uh no it's uh it was a good day uh today
i played
uh played a lot better than than i did
yesterday and the day before um it was
more of a
typical performance in that sense
with with some decent chess so i'm
really
i'm really happy with that uh and um
yeah no qualif are qualified for for the
next stage and i can
start looking forward to that so heading
into the knockout stage are you feeling
that that killer mode that you wanted to
to be and is it coming now
i think it's coming for sure uh didn't
feel like
in too much of a killer mode today but i
i just think that the positions weren't
um ones that that weren't at that
particular
particular mode so i think today was
more a case of
i played a lot more accurately a lot
better than i
did the day days before and it really
um it really uh boosted my confidence
throughout
the day not to be to be missing so many
things and i'm wondering
uh and mine is we are currently watching
the game between icarus gary i
i don't know if you're seeing what's
happening on the board here but anish
giri
he's been fighting today and and quite
not like we've used to see
him fighting for those draws he's really
been fighting are you are you uh
entertained by by his games today
uh yeah i think um you
clearly in a desperate position uh
coming into today
uh considering the tournament standing
so it's it's clear that he needed to
to fight but it looks like he will uh
it will not be enough because uh he
needs to win and you're
never ever winning this position ah okay
there we have the
the answer to this and okay magnus
finally obviously if you have no idea
who
you're gonna be facing in the
quarterfinals right now right now in the
standings it is alexander grishock but
is it
someone you're hoping for or someone
you're really hoping you're not going to
face
yeah i'm okay with everybody great
looking forward to seeing the killer and
sing tomorrow magnus thank you for
joining us
thank you and i guess he gave us the
answer
no way is anish geary winning this
position that's right so
material is level at the moment both
sides have the same pieces the same
pawns
but i think the best black can hope for
is a draw and we see it with hikaru like
nakamura's last move just pushing a pawn
forward at the corner there
we've also mentioned this knights are
extremely bad at stopping these corner
pawns
these corner pawns and actually white's
corner pawn here is very far away from
the black king for example so
not many pieces can stop it hikaru
nakamura he's going to keep pushing his
pawn there on the left side
um that pawn will race through even if
any shigeru stops that pawn
the most likely scenario is that he'll
get a draw
um a couple of pawns might come off the
knight might come off the best black
home hopeful is a draw here hey kara
nakamura is the only one who can win
this position yeah
unfortunately this is the problem with
this must win situation because
you know anish really is suffering and i
i'm not even sure whether he'll get the
draw
yeah i think um hikara is a big favorite
to win this yeah i i think that
the situation demands so much from him
that uh okay and there we have a very
risky scenario
from uh hikaru hakara just pushes the
pawn
forward he doesn't care about the knight
i love it
wow that's a big big decision and if we
bring up the analysis board we can see
that's a night sacrifice
white is offering a knight here he did
not protect this piece which was
attacked in the middle of the board
this octo knight black can capture it
but there would be consequences we
talked about this
this corner pawn okay anishiri has
captured it we'll see a few quick moves
white gives check to the black king the
black king has to sidestep white pawn is
about to promote
into a new queen right now white's trap
is that he will
he will sacrifice his rook in order to
create a free square for his pawn
uh to promote so now white will
sacrifice his rook he'll give a check
black would be forced to capture and
white will make a new queen
and white is winning this game um hikaru
nakamura he's
inches away he's just two or three moves
away from winning now
and ishiguri he took risks but it will
backfire
it's all due to him like taking that
pawn he
opened up the position when this knight
was so badly placed
okay so now okay now i think we're going
to see
the game ending yeah
is actually looking really sad yeah
because it's like
this is when it dawns on you that the
tournament is over
and no one likes to be eliminated and
especially when uh
you know and he did really into
entertainers he won a lot of games he
he lost a lot of games and he really
fought very hard
yeah we should also mention though that
he's not completely
lost in this position yet but black has
no winning chances therefore andy shkuri
will be out
if we do a bit quicker a quick bit of
maths i was going to say
just the idea of mathematics scares me
right now if we do some maths
we can count actually the material is
still still equal
on the board white has a queen worth
nine points in return black has a rook a
knight
and a pawn those are also worth nine
points but the problem is
that the queen is just too powerful she
will dominate
the uh the black rook the black knight
and the queen will target pawns on the
right side and the left side black will
be forced
uh anishkiri will be forced to just kind
of curl up into a ball and hope that he
could just
create a fortress and defend everything
um
the queen is the one though that will do
all the work and
i think hikaru nakamura should win this
game yeah
i agree with you david yeah there's the
chances for a fortress but
i completely agree the problem is that
white hat you know with the queen
with pawns being on the left side and
the right side you know this is just too
much for the rook and knight to
coordinate if it was a rook and a bishop
perhaps but uh and the night here has no
posts whatsoever
knights like to be supported by pawns
and that poor knight
at the edge all alone
he keeps making the same mistake his
knight got off the edge of the board but
now it's back on the edge of the board
um yeah that night if it were right in
the center there
somewhere if if it were anchored by a
pawn
it would be perhaps uh enough to hold
the position as black but that black
knight is just
so sad right now um anishikari he's just
leaning back
closing his eyes he looks resigned to
the fact
that he will be eliminated unfortunately
after this game hmm
it really reminds me of that football
quote they think it's all over
it is now although probably i'll eat my
words faster
chess is cruel he won a game earlier
today he probably thought
you know he was just out of the danger
but just when he's out of danger they
pull him back in
and yeah this black rook has had to
retreat and white now is going after
that black pawn
yeah all right well they are still
playing and anishkiri he's not winning
this game so he will be
out of the air things monster and
probably will start uh preparing for
um another tournament tata steel which
is an over the board tournament i
think he's definitely playing that being
a dutch yeah he's
the local favorite in that tournament
and um yeah that's one of the
kind of super tournaments that we talk
about with all of the top players in the
world often playing there
this year they've got a very young
energetic field as well
and i think that will take place in late
january so anishikari has got a lot to
look forward to
in the new year so that tournament the a
few of these players will be playing
there i think
sort of getting ready for the next
champions chess tour tournament
which is in the start of february yes
i'd love to see uh love to ask them what
their approach will be to the quarantine
that they might have to take
and also their new year's resolutions uh
what their goals are just
uh the chess in 2021 yeah exactly
all right well it is an ishkiri thinking
he's right there going under
five minutes on the clock i mean uh does
the clock have anything to say or
say here or is it just danish being very
that is he knows he's not winning this
game
uh yeah i think he knows he's not
winning this game he's actually hiding
his face right now
i've been there many times over the
board you know you know you're losing
your opponent knows he's winning
um you don't want the world to see you
so you kind of cover your face and i
think that's what anish giri's doing
right now
um the clock isn't his friend he is four
minutes down
but i think even worse than the clock is
his
situation on the board and obviously we
are paying attention to
all the games going on in this final
round of the preliminaries because not
only will four players be out but it
also is a mutual fuel phase two in the
quarter finals
number one will face number eight and i
think number one is magnus carlsen
he's gonna phase number one number two
will face number seven so it's very
interesting
and actually we see um a few games might
be decided with a winner
uh this one is one of the games and then
we also see wesley so
mr draw looks like he's winning against
danielle dubo right now
and actually i think there might be some
drama still remaining because
anish giri he took risks in this game he
wasn't happy with the draw
but the two players above him in the
table
alexander grishock and daniel dubois
they're both losing so it might turn out
that a draw would have been enough for
him to qualify
will he have gambled away his chances i
mean daniel dubois and grisham they're
both losing right now we can tell
below the players so if he keeps his
optimism
and just saying there is the possibility
that there may be might be some
fortresses
um maybe there's still everything to
play for because i can just see a
scenario where
white runs runs with that pawn on the
left side
forces black to sacrifice well not
sacrifice to give up the night for that
pawn
and then somehow the rook can just hold
that's right rooks are tricky pieces
they're i mean they're
called castles sometimes and you can
just tell by the structure
they're just hard to break down and
white's queen
might find itself facing off against the
black root later there will still be
some
small drawing chances but the problem
for a niche gear though is that
if he is on the same score as um grishok
and daniel dubo
then he he lost against donald dubock
behind those two players
okay but against alexander grishtra that
was um a draw
and grishtrook against dubois that was a
draw ah
okay yeah unfortunately it has so
i i mean there's so many things to
calculate but i definitely think
anishigiri needs to win here
his fate is definitely not in his hands
meanwhile nakamura
he's he's kind of he hasn't lost his
advantage he's butchering it slightly
though he's shaking his head
he's just for no reason at all he's
allowed that black knight
into the center of the board he didn't
need to do that um
black's knight now nicely centralized
coordinating with the black rook
black's rook is anchored by a pawn
black's knight is anchored by the rook
um and he should be his position's
improved at least over the last two
years
some uh some hope but still it's a big
ask
um i i don't i think uh
i think hikaru is being slightly
dramatic about it all
and we like the drama though
because uh yes i think he's still got a
fantastic position yeah and white's
queen there
getting into the heart of the black
territory trying to attack the black
pawns
black's king meanwhile steps forward
keeping all of the pawns protected
so at the moment everything in black's
army defends each other
therefore hikaru nakamura he needs to
come up with something a bit special
to win this game white's i mean the
thing he's banking on
basically is that pawn there on the left
side of the board that's his trump card
white's trump card he wants to run that
pawn to the end but
the black knight and the black rook will
try and stop it
nakamura meanwhile pushes pawns on the
other side he pushed the pawns on the
right flank and that's just try
to try and cage that black king um
black's king
will be a target it always is when
you're facing a queen
um and hikaru nakamura very sensible
stuff
just pushing some pawns on the right
side there but sooner or later he'll
launch his other pawn
on the other flank yeah he has to start
moving things on both sides and this is
the beauty of the queen the queen can
just play on both
both and can also actually lose time
which in case a rook really can't and
uh yeah and i'm really
really gonna enjoy seeing white hassel
the black king
that poor black king um is a bit stuck
right now
um it's hard to even find a useful move
for black
especially with three minutes left on
the clock um
yeah everything's against him the
position the clock um
his king is weak white has this extra
pawn on that left side
yeah anishikari is still fighting and
that's why these players are so good
they always fight
you need to beat them two three times in
a game and they will not let
they will not lie down and let you um
just kind of
uh fulfill all your plans they will
always find counterplay they will always
find tricks
um anishigiri has to be looking for
those tricks i do not like that last
move though
by initially black pushes a pawn forward
to the center
normally this is what we want earlier in
the game but now
that black pawn it was keeping the black
rook defended
black's rook is now temporarily a bit
vulnerable
at least and maybe white can try and
take advantage of that
in the short term yeah it still looks
like hikaru nakamura is winning this
yeah absolutely i mean he's well on
track to winning it i mean it's just a
question of how he can break through
and it's also a question of whether
anish will himself crack or whether he
will just manage to find
a fortress somewhere in along the line
and
uh chances are not good
but you never know what is time control
yeah
and with things speeding up people make
mistakes and we have to say the knights
are the craftiest
pieces on the board they jump forwards
backwards sideways
and can be quite confusing well if
fikara nakamura wins this game
he will be on six and a half points
wesley so just won his game actually as
i was looking down
uh against daniel dubose that means
wesley so is on six and a half is uh if
also hikara nakamura is on sixth and
half then
magnus carlsen will still be the winner
beating hikaru nakamura
all right wow and we need to bring up
the analysis board
black has just sacrificed a rook but
it's a trick it's a trap
we talked about how how uh kind of
devious those nights can be
and with his last move anish giri he's
ignoring this threat against this rook
hikaru nakamura he did not capture this
rook because this would have walked into
a fork
one of kaya's favorite types of moves
black would have now jumped forward
giving check to the white king
and attacking this queen at the same
time white's king would have to move
and suddenly a full turnaround black
would win the white queen and black has
this extra night and would win the game
so
this is why we can never relax too early
even when we've got an extra queen
in chess there's always these tricks
especially with knights these forks
something to look out for let's just
look at hikaru you know with his last
move he was like i'm cool
i'm cool you have you know you've left
your rook on breeze but i'm simply going
to advance my pawn
that was the consequence your knight
moved away and so i think and
now hikaru probably must
not hikari anish must move the rook and
there we go we have a rook move and now
the rook is attacking
both of these pawns and it's going to
come to that situation
where one of the pawns is gonna try and
make itself a queen
oh and i'm gonna see that maybe anish
can try to give up the knight that's
what he's gonna hope for and hopefully
that rook
can hold some kind of fortress
all right we have another game finished
it is a draw between timor ajabo
and penta lahari krishna so bentley hari
krishna is out of the tournament
while team rajabo is safe with six
points
we will see him in the quarterfinals and
we do have some moves
yeah so aneesh giri he's trying to
defend here he did win of one
uh he did win one of white's pawns on
that right side now he desperately needs
to get rid of
white's remaining pawn on the left flank
as ivanka mentioned if he can i mean it
still needs a miracle
if he can give up that black knight for
that white pawn
he has some small chances to draw the
game um
it won't be easy white is going to be
greedy nakamura he wants another queen
he wants a second queen on the board
but nietzsche if he wants to have a
chance of surviving this tournament he
needs to draw this game
and now he knows he might be able to see
on his screen that dubov has lost
gristrok is losing as well he'll with a
draw he'll jump up to the same points as
them
and at least mathematically there's a
small chance he might be saved
uh by the tie breaks um we'll see he's
ticking down under two minutes though
i'm actually i'm just i'm just sitting
here
trying to calculate this looking at the
table and i mean i'm i'm right now
looking at maxim vagiela
grav we almost wrote him off in the last
round but he's about
to win the game against alexander
grishock and then maxim will be
on five points i think actually the game
finished
okay wow uh maxim bajiella we wrote him
off we thought it was all over for him
but he beat alexander krishna
uh that means that they both have five
points uh no
yeah and and winning that game makes him
must be
and he also didn't pentala hari krishna
is on five points
if i think if giri saves this there's a
chance
there is a chance because we will then
have uh
five players on five points oh wow
because yeah he did beat maxine vazquez
earlier today so his head-to-head is
good against some players it's positive
he will be kicking himself and he's
going that he didn't head for a draw
straight from the opening
opening in this game he did take those
risks and he might get punished
um meanwhile yeah anish giri he's
advancing his king as black that's brave
very very brave he's only got one minute
left though um
imagine last time in the spinning open
it came down to the last seconds we
still didn't know who qualified
imagine if anishiri pulled it out of the
bag again okay well he's threatening
checkmate now so
this is going to give always a bit of
thrill of excitement
um yep that knight has moved in and is
now controlling the two squares that the
king can
fly to and uh yeah yeah he is on
yes with his last move if we bring up
the analysis board anishiri he's created
a threat he's still
trying to set those traps for hikaru
nakamura to fall into
if white gets careless and pushes the
pawn one square closer to making a queen
this would be a huge blunder black's
rook would come and give check
and suddenly white king is trapped the
knight covers the two escape squares
for this king therefore hikaru nakamura
he sidesteps that threat he moves his
king across one square
and okay it's still odds on the hikara
nakamura will win but and it's going to
be trying
everything throwing everything at this
game well i'm almost hoping that anita
is paying attention to the other games
and the table and that he knows that
wow actually he can save it he can
qualify
maybe if he gets a draw here yeah well
that's that's the beauty of online chess
you actually don't really know
because yes you could potentially look
at the scores you
somehow you get so absorbed with the
games you don't realize and so
i think uh maybe anish just thinks okay
i i have to win and
maybe the bet draws the best i can do
and actually we have some great people
in the control room
grand master young ludwig is sitting and
he's calculating uh
constantly here and he just uh sent me a
message saying
a draw will save anish giri because he
has won against maxim bashirov
and hari krishna who are both on five
points so
according to um grandmaster young lady
becomer
the draw would save anishigiri i just
can't believe that maxine washington
after we had ridden him off yeah yeah
after his loss
that was it that was over and then
suddenly he is
in seventh place as things stand so he's
kind of hoping that uh
he'll be hoping that nakamura wins this
game because um
remember vashti the graph lost to giri
so those head to head would be worsened
by that result
meanwhile anish geary he's retreated his
knight he created those checkmate
threats but they didn't quite work
white white's king escape to safety so
anish giri he needs to sacrifice his
knight
for that white pawn on the left flank if
anish giri could sacrifice his knight
for that pawn
he will possibly hold this game um
that's what he needs to do
but his clock situation 20 seconds
against nakamura six minutes
it's not easy uh i think maybe one
saving grace one thing that i wish i
could tell anish right now is
that game that i mentioned to you guys
earlier that i drew against nakamura
he had a queen i had a rook and a knight
and i managed to draw so
it's very very similar to that situation
there is
uh there is a track record if of hikaru
failing to win those types of positions
okay
okay wow this is this is really getting
interesting you know
i'm so curious clear as if geary is
sitting there
sort of aware of the tournament
situation and and that he can actually
save this with a draw
yeah in a way maybe it's better not to
be aware so he could fully focus on the
game maybe his nerves will be
kind of accentuated if he if he does
realize that the other games have gone
all in his favor he couldn't have hoped
for better results in the other games to
be fair
and the another game has finished david
anton has beaten levon aronian
unfortunately david anton is out of the
tournament he was before this round but
but a nice ending for him and levon
aronian
uh with five and a half points he he is
safe and we will see the one ronin in
the quarterfinals
so the question is about those players
on five points and the niche gary who
will be on five points
if he gets a draw here oh and the the
trouble just
keeps mounting because hikaru has just
moved the queen to attack the pawn and
the rook oh my goodness me and this
and now things are looking even worse
because that white pawn
has reached one square further it's one
square away from a queening
and i think he's well i know that he's
planning to okay it's going to be over
isn't it
it's over he can just he can just
promote the pawn i think okay
we see hikara nakamura play a joke there
he promoted to a rook
instead of a queen and anishieri has had
to resign
um we'll go over that moment over on the
board at some point but
hikara nakamura did find a way to win
and shiri fell at the final hurdle
he was so close to qualifying so
close um he didn't manage he needed a
draw in this game and
he might have qualified um
obviously hikaru nakamura with a win
here uh he is safe he is on six and a
half points with
wesley so and magnus carlton magnus
colson is the winner
of the preliminaries and i'm just gonna
update update update the
the result list here to to find out who
is okay
are you ready to hear who the two final
players are
like simba legrand is in seventh place
we wrote him completely off the
frenchman but he is ready for the
quarter
finals and then we also have daniel
dubom in eighth place
wow okay uh i'm so surprised maxim
actually made it here
that final win against alexander grisham
was all he needed we see the results
here from the final preliminary
round hikaru nakamura getting that
decisive win against anish kyrie or
anishikari getting that decisive loss
wesley so winning finally a game against
daniel dubov
and timor raja beau played a draw
against penta lahari krishna
janan pomnyachi minus thousand that was
a quick draw levonoronian lost actually
to david anton but levon neroni and we
will see in the quarter finals david
danson is out
alexander grishock lost that decisive
game against maximum vascular grave and
that means
krishuk is out maxim is in yeah and
actually this is the second tournament
in a row we wrote off maxine before the
final round and
twice he's shocked us and climbed up i
mean we we heard yesterday he has this
degree in mathematics maybe he knew all
along those tiebreaks gave him a chance
and
yeah he won when he needed to win yeah
that was a crunch game right there at
the end because he
actually defeated one of his rivals
alexander grishik so absolutely amazing
stuff
yeah amazing heartbreak for any girly
but delight for the french fans and
fantastic that we see that
starting to winning games in the last
day that's that's
all that matters the players who who did
that who actually maximize
lost against giri but won this final
game and that was what he needed
that was just what he needed and that
was enough to get him through to
the quarterfinals and uh have a spot
against a
huge number to hikaru wow okay well we
do know now that magnus carlsen will
face
daniel dubo in the quarter finals uh i
mean
daniel dubo a young guy but he is in
magnus carlsen's coaching team that's
going to be interesting
yeah and also there's history between
them even during this tournament
magnus carlsen did grind out that long
long victory against daniel dubov
dubov his young pretender he'll be
looking to strike back
against his employer i guess and uh yeah
that one
it's so exciting both players love to go
for the win yeah exactly
i can't wait for that one that is like
for me the dream matchup
you know i would have loved to see that
in the final but i'm seeing it in the
quarterfinal and i couldn't have asked
more
and then we will have uh wesley so who
will play maximum vagiela
that's going to be interesting too yes
that would be certainly interesting
because you know
wesley has been very strategic during
these preliminaries he's done enough and
you know he's come up with some
amazing victories at the right minute
and we saw him
absolutely ferocious in the skilling
open and i'm looking forward to seeing
that wesley come back
into our screens and we are right now
joined
by maxim vagierla graham who has uh just
in the last minute qualified for the
quarterfinals congratulations maxime
oh he's struggling with his sound
can you hear us now maxim
some technical issues there we will wait
to hear from maximum vagina
he must be feeling so happy i'm so
excited to talk to him yeah and
actually that confidence might carry
through he's got that momentum now it
might carry through into the knockout
rounds and
he'll think that if he can survive today
if you can survive
having two difficult days anything uh is
possible in the rest of the time
we are working with the sound here now
we did get that final win
against alexander grishard in the last
uh in the last round we didn't follow
that game but
um do you think he played something
risky there i'm just um
looking at the clock and actually maxim
finished with 11 minutes on the clock
versus 11 seconds for alexander grishard
so it seemed he was very solid in that
last game yes
um yeah and actually the final position
there was actually a mouse slip by
alexander gristrok
he was losing anyway but all remaining
chances he had were
ruined by a mouse lip so maxine rashford
riding his luck in more ways than one oh
we see it here actually
yes and we see it here so actually we're
looking from the white side
and this black pawn maxine vasily grav
playing black this black pawn is
very close to promotion but alexander
struck he tried to capture this pawn
it was white's move he tried to take it
but due to the mouselip he dropped his
rook
on the wrong square he dropped it one
move too short
allowing black to make a new queen and
actually he didn't even wait for that
new queen to enter the board he resigned
after making this
terrible mouse slip if he had played
rook takes pawn
he might have been able to continue the
game uh black would capture a pawn here
and the fight goes on black is still the
favorite black has two
versus white's one but this would have
led to a very tense finish instead
a mouse slip and anded alexander
grisham's tournament it ended alexander
grisham's tournament but maximum
margiela grab
is now ready for the quarterfinals again
maxim congratulations
yeah thank you uh it's very undeserved
no oh my play today but i'll take it
anyway
definitely i mean we were we almost we
have to admit we almost wrote you off
after uh round 10 and and then in round
11 you're coming back with a win here
were you almost surprised there to see
that it it actually took you to seventh
place
uh totally i knew it was not completely
over if i won but
given the course of the game i didn't
expect to have any winning chances and
then
i don't know what went through such as
mine but he gave me uh
way too many chances out of absolutely
nowhere
so uh magazine we have followed a lot of
your games it's been so entertaining to
to watch you play here we know
uh you are one of the leaders in the
candidates tournaments and you have told
us that you sort of wanna
you don't wanna give away all your good
openings now in this tournament heading
into
the candidate sometime in 2021
have you tried to experiment a little
bit so far in this tournament
well i've been experimenting for for a
while now but
uh i mean i have
not yet a good idea of what i will play
in the candidate so i mean i have an
idea but
now i have many ideas that i can use and
we'll see what happens in the actual
candidates in terms of openings
and we are actually also joined now by
anish giri to very different destinies
here in in their things monsters
maximum just about making it to the
quarterfinals and each unfortunately
we're not going to see you play
quarterfinals how are you after
that final game yeah no i didn't expect
maxi will make it actually i mean i
also i don't even know how he finished
against rajava but i think he was lost
from the opening there
so i thought he was doing very badly but
uh wow he mounted a great comeback
and uh i'm i'm quite concerned i think
maybe draw would have been also good for
me in the last round then
um that didn't occur to me at all i was
sure i'm in the master situation
so yeah i i didn't really get anywhere
the opening went really badly
um and i want to ask both of you because
yesterday okay we had
21 out of 24 games ending in draws
how is the mentality different going
into
to today when you know both of you and
many players had to start winning i'll
start with you maxim
um yeah honestly i just wanted to play
chess from the start
and in the first two days i mean the
wizards were not so great but
i had lots of opportunities so i mean to
be honest
i played so so badly so like i had
fighting games
at least because well anish was in a
must win against me
and then i was white and then
i don't know how but i got chances
against sasha but
yeah my level of play was terrible so i
need to purchase that
starting tomorrow how about you and age
we've been so entertained with seeing
you
maybe more than we used to seeing you
really fight for for wins in this
tournament
um no actually
yeah i was in a tough spot um i think
the format is not very good uh
i mean first you would make eight
players qualify for 12 spots and then
you complain every day about
draws from players i mean that's that's
not very um
i mean it's either one or the other and
for me i wasn't i was not in the luxury
position of playing it safe so i had to
go all out today even um in the last
round with the black pieces as well so
yeah i was
uh i had to fight for my life but
unfortunately it didn't really work out
i'm i think the opening in the last game
was went really badly and position i got
was very very bad
actually if i would have had a
controlled game then maybe even um
even a draw would have been enough i
didn't count the tie breaks but i've
beaten maxime and uh also anton so maybe
um maybe i would have would have made it
even i don't know i have to see but uh
anyway yeah i mean i i was not one of
the people who
who could afford to just sit and wait uh
but i in the other hand it's quite
impressive for example wesley's uh
wesley's playing these events i mean
it's so it's so incredibly
good and it's it's as though you
either just make a draw with him from
the get-go or if you don't you get
punished
severely so yeah he managed to play very
very good event
um again and i mean such such results
are
inspiring i mean mostly you know if you
if you play it safe in too many games
then you start feeling bad about
yourself and then playing badly
eventually
but some players in particular
in particular wesley and also hikaru
they don't feel bad at all and
you know if they play for a draw they
make it if they play for a win they also
win so i mean
well what can you do
[Laughter]
and well uh yes david yeah i mean
commiserations
um anish we we were greatly entertained
by your games today i just wanted to ask
about your new year's resolutions for
2021 and your
goals and chess wow i didn't think of it
like that but it's true it's a good
moment to think about it and the only
good thing about being knocked out here
early is that i have
a little more time now to prepare for my
next tournament and
to think about life in general and yeah
i mean i'm uh
i need to calm down a bit after today's
games um other than that
you know it's always the same i'm a
professional chess player i focus on my
my chest so much and uh when it comes to
new year's resolutions it's also usually
something to do with chess i just try to
improve my game and can get better every
time
yeah hopefully hopefully um especially
i'm looking forward to my next
tournament it's going to be a uh
hopefully vikings a tournament it's live
live event in in the netherlands
um you know it's a tough time to host an
event but uh
well it's something different uh you
know we are used now to playing online
which is
tremendous events that you guys are
hosting here but uh
yeah i'm looking forward also to see how
the over the board event will
pan out yeah and uh how much holiday do
you give yourself
after an event such as this to both of
you
well it depends uh how much time i get
between
one event and the other one
so you don't go like for me i go give
myself one day off or maybe two days off
you don't you you just uh well
technically i mean
if i make it to the final i will have to
go to to bike and see
um very soon after because of the
quarantine there
so we'll see how that goes but um anyway
like
if i have a week off of course i will
generally take
a few days off before going back to
to chess activities i mean i have lots
of things
i can do uh in between the chess
but no time for you to take a break now
uh maxine because tomorrow
quarterfinals start and you will face
wesley so how will you
make sure that he just doesn't go for
those super quick draws in the beginning
there
uh well i don't know exactly i just need
to
you know we focus on my chess play
play better be in better shape because
yeah that was in
actual awful shape and plundering
everything so
you know i'll take the gifts
of qualifying but i know that i cannot
afford to play like this against western
you're you're smiling a niche the
problem is not the draws the problem is
the losses you have it all wrong
i said it okay that's it that's it
that's it
well well anish can we have your expert
tip for
the air things monsters who do you think
will do the best here
uh yeah it's uh all these players are so
good i mean magnus and wesley
magnus and hicary were always known to
be good and this year wesley got uh
i mean lately wesley got a lot more
opportunities he didn't get too many
invites in the first tour but now the
second one he got and he's showing great
play
i mean these three guys i think are head
and shoulders above
i mean no offense to maximo is also a
great player but i think so far they've
proven at least so far yeah
they've proven uh and they've played
very high quality chess as well
all three of them and yeah these three
are favorites
in my book but uh yeah everybody
qualified and also everybody who was
invited are very good and the maxim of
course
if he finds his form as a tremendous
player also the rajabov can be very very
um
robust and uh strong and you know in
these close matches
um he might also do very well so we'll
see we'll see
all right anish one final question we
know that you've
recently released a video course for
chessable on the night off
and we've discovered it's kaya's
favorite opening any tips for anyone out
there
um on learning the opening it's not only
kaia's favorite
not only kai's favorite opening it's uh
yeah it's a it's a great opening that
many people uh
like and play because it's it's very
fighting of opening
and offers you lots of chances and maxim
actually played it all his life
now that's now that finally my course is
out and he can finally learn to play
neither
the right way essentially he switched he
switched to this other opening called
the classical sedan
which is of course much worse but uh
yeah well um
i'm i mean uh i don't know for kaya i
think um
um yeah i'm not sure i think some of the
variations are going to be
uh a little too deep for for kaya
because you know it's also
it's also a repair that i try to um
they might be also a bit too deep for me
thank you maxim but in general yeah i
try to make it something that
can be also valid for players of a high
level
so yeah yeah but it but it's it's fun
i'm sure
you'll enjoy it thank you so much now
both of you thank you so much anish for
for joining us and we wish you good luck
in the next tournament and maxine we
wish you good luck when the coach
violence starts tomorrow thank you so
much both of you
yeah thank you maximum last thing you
still have time before next round to
check out
the course and the switch and fix your
1e4 1-4 repurchase you still have the
time if you start now
in 24 hours you're there yeah yeah well
but i won't understand your lines
anyways
there are so many arrows so many arrows
i'm sure so many hours
okay we know what you have to do now
that maxim
straight in to look at that yeah
thank you so much both of you definitely
what i will do
great thank you both of you thank you
thank you
all right well i need geary he's uh he's
not too sad
numerous still there no he's still there
and i i really liked uh maxine basha's
grass
dry yeah yeah that's just just what i'm
gonna do that's what we like to see
players giving each other homework
exactly yes do you think actually maxim
will sort of
you asked him you know is it normal to
take a break after a tournament
do you think he will take a break uh
tonight maxim or is it now starting to
look forward to the quarterfinals
yeah i think tonight he might relax a
little bit today's been very stressful
for everyone involved all the players
the nerves jangling but
um yeah he'll be fresh ready to go
tomorrow wow okay
um i think it's time to look at the uh
the standings
after the preliminaries um
we started with 12 players it is a major
tournament so that means only 12 players
this is the final result of the
preliminaries magnus carlsen is
the winner on the same score is wesley
so and hikar nakamura but he
he does have a better head-to-head score
against these players beating hikaru
nakamura
and then we have jana pomnyachi and team
rajabov on six points
levon ronyan uh on five and a half and
then
in the end here my sim machi alagrav
managed to qualify with five points
the neil dubo just about qualified and i
mean we have to even if we're missing
we're going to miss alex on the great
show
we're going to miss all the four players
that leave us but this is a fantastic
setup for the quarterfinals yeah this is
absolutely dream you know these are some
fantastic players and we heard it from
anita actually
magnus carlsen wesley so hikaru are
playing astounding chess
so i'm really looking forward to this
tomorrow is going to be so exciting
yeah and it's hard to predict a winner
anyone could win it these are eight of
the best speed players the best rapid
players
in the world and um i for one know
there's going to be some surprises along
the way
and who has impressed you the most so
far i mean
i we talked the first days about levon
aronian seemed very
uh focused who's impressed you the most
of it oh it's tough to say
i mean magnus carlsen it feels like he's
stepping up his game at the right moment
we said he struggled in the first two
days he only got the one win and that
was a bit of a lucky one but today he
showed his quality and that's why he
ended up at top of the tables
he said the world champion yuanka he he
wants to get into that killer mode
and he felt maybe he's starting to get
there do you think we'll see even more
great play for yeah it was a bit scary
the accuracy that he played and he put
the pressure on hikaru it was like
watching some formula
first of all he just um you know he
started off quiet
and he upped the pressure then he upped
even more and then
hikaru just cracked and if you think
about it hikaru is one of the strongest
players in the world
and magnus did that to him very easily
wow all right well ladies and gentlemen
then we have
uh the quarterfinals starting tomorrow
and this is what they will
look like it's going to be magnus
carlsen against daniel dubo and that's
so interesting we talked about it
delhi duba is one of the seconds of
magnus carlsen
yes he's one of the seconds and he's
such an uncompromising player he can be
brilliant i mean for me he played the
game of the tournament and that was
already just on the first day
and it was just fantastic to see so i'm
expecting
a full-on fight fantastic and then yana
pomnyacci timora jabo who is the
favorite than that one david
i think this is going to be one of the
tightest quarter-finals actually
um it's hard to say we met we heard
anikiri mention that timor rajabov he's
so robust he rarely ever loses games
and he actually thrives in one-on-one
knockout tournaments he won the most
recent world cup
in 2019 um that being said janna
pogbachie has been great form lately
russian champion
um napomnechi's slight favorite but too
close to cool
and then we have hikar nakamura against
levon neronian jamaica
who's your bet on here well i think i'll
have to bet on hikaru nakamura he was so
impressive in that game against anish
giri it was such a powerful display
so my money is on him and then finally
wesley saw against maxim
bashir lagrave well maxim just about
qualified do you think that
energy from the last round i'm going to
take him all the way in the quarter
finals
i'm hoping at the very least that he
will be happy with his
um his performances in these
quarter-finals obviously wesley so
rarely loses he's so hard to beat but as
maxime said
he's aiming to peak at the right time
and if he does anything can happen in
that quarter final
all right well the quarter final set up
is ready four players will now leave us
and eight players are
ready for quarter finals and also we
have a winner
of today's uh twitter quiz or twitter
question
yes so uh of a twitter question what was
the
what was your best chess inspired name
for a pet
we had some great answers including
yours bobby the fish
kato khan was one of my favorites um but
the winner is pavel with stalemate
with a chess ball he's got a great name
stalemate
such a cute dog as well i know i want
that dog
stanley looks so cozy fantastic and he
will obviously get one year subscription
to chess24 premium yes and of course
that they will contact him
in a few days with his prize fantastic
all right
stalemate the dog i think that was
actually the dog's name so that's
very fun um okay ladies and gentlemen
that was the preliminaries in the first
major and the champions chester air
things masters
tomorrow the knockout stages start with
the first quarter final so that's going
to be
so excited we hope you join us again
then we start every day on
championshipstore.com
at 2 45 cet so we hope to see you again
for more chess fun tomorrow
thank you for joining us today goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you